[Music]
so you started mountain biking
a couple years ago yeah
right after actually right after tony
died i like uh i quit drinking right
after tony died and i started mountain
biking a lot and
and had a
just i mean i got like you know i i try
to i tend to overdo it with everything
so mellow like trail mountain biking on
the fire roads quickly turned into like
enduro charging on these like diy kind
of ridiculous enduro courses that they
build around here that are totally
unpredictable like really unpredictable
lips on the jumps and stuff like that
and i ended up just hammering one of
these things and had just a horrific
crash i broke my nose my nose was
sideways i was all torn up i made my way
back to the main trail and these two
russian guys actually helped me out you
know you're in bad shape when the
russian guys have to help you out that's
right yeah but the difference the
profound difference in like having that
fall at 44 as opposed to the last time i
had ridden when i was young is it's
unreal i'd never broken anything i'd
never even hurt myself and it's like i
just shattered on the ground it was like
dropping like a china plate
oh
so bad it's so bad so this is a perfect
way to segue and we'll get to the bio in
a second yeah sure
so you are
or at points have have been and have
also self-described as a very physical
shooter and if i'm remembering correctly
please please call
bs on me if i'm misremembering but you
told me a story
about running i want to say on a
football field while filming yeah could
you just briefly tell that story to give
people an idea of what physical shooter
means give
you might give an additional example
after that but i just remember
almost losing my lunch with that one so
why don't we start there well this was
kind of the depressing example
but uh yeah we're we're shooting a
documentary
me and my longtime friend todd lubin
i'm still in contact with
we're shooting a documentary in 2003 on
a football team in
south carolina coastal carolina who's
gone on to become like d2 champions i
mean they're like players in the nfl and
stuff it's a really good program now but
uh i was trying to run sprints while
holding the camera sideways along with
you know the players as they were
running sprints i started with like the
o-line and it's like the o-line guys you
can keep up with the o-line guys right
and so i got all cocky feeling like i
was like hot [ __ ] running with the
o-line guys who were like i'm 15 years
older than i tried to run with the
running backs it was like i was racing a
ferrari in a shopping cart
so i'm running down the side and i
stepped in a hole and just
obliterated my knee just blew it to
shreds but the dumbest thing i did
was i went i flew to new hampshire i got
an mri and flew back and finished the
show i shot another two months on the on
the knee before getting surgery
and i regret it every day because it's
just i i mean it's just a disaster now i
didn't know that everything's amplified
when you get older you know yeah you
ever climbed up the top of a mast on a
sailboat when you're out at sea
i wish i could say yes but i haven't
well i've done this more than once it
but it's kind of mellow when you're on
the deck you're kind of rolling and
stuff when you're realizing at the top
of a 60-foot mask those
little bit of rolling there is like
these massive 20-foot
swing
swings
and you just get shredded that's what
growing old is with injuries at the
point of injury it was kind of mellow
you know i was like i can roll with this
i'm tough you know i got tons of
hormones still like producing in my body
and i can do anything i didn't i just
didn't realize that at 46 now
the the effect of that would be so
amplified that uh that i basically spent
my life limping around you know well you
and me both you and me both but i feel
like you have you have better stories to
tell most of mine are just from terrible
decisions and questionable circumstances
but
before we get any further
let me just read this bio
which was fun to read because i don't i
don't know if i've actually read a bio
of yours before obviously we've spent
some time together but let me let me
just jump into this all right so morgan
fallon on twitter at diamond mo fallon
is a nine-time emmy nominated executive
producer director and
is born and raised in new england and
studied film at emerson college in
boston first question is probably going
to be what you learned and did not learn
in your film courses at emerson after
graduating he spent three years working
for his mentor director michael mann and
in 2007 he began a long-term working
relationship with producers chris
collins and lydia tanalia and their new
york-based production company 0.0
productions through his tenure at zpz
fallon focused primarily on work with
zpz creative partner anthony bourdain on
several episodic series and
documentaries produced by bourdain
including the emmy-winning mind of a
chef the theatrically distributed
documentary the last magnificent and the
emmy peabody pga tca and ace
award-winning series anthony bourdain
parts unknown which fallon shot directed
and produced throughout the series 103
episode run
currently he is a director and executive
producer for the emmy winning series
united shades of america with w kamau
bell he lives in california with his
wife and production partner gillian
brown and his two children you can find
them like i mentioned on twitter at
diamondmo fallon instagram fallon.morgan
and i'll include the facebook and
everything else in the show notes and
the website for 0.0 is
0.0.com and now we're back so morgan aka
mo thank you thank you thank you thank
you
you have seen me read a lot of scripts
and look into a lot of lights and
maybe we'll cover
some of that ground and do a lot of
stuff we did a lot of stuff i mean you
were the only you talk about physical
shooter like
you were headlong into that project well
you know you want to talk about like
things that you roll with and then you
realize now
you're at the top of the mast in a
squall
that parkour episode which was the first
exactly
i am still fixing injuries from that
episode
oh
of the tempest experiment oh god and it
just seemed like such a great idea at
the time
i know but you're jumping in with people
who had been doing that forever and
those kind of athletes when they get to
that point they're like a purpose-built
race car yeah that's that is what they
are designed for and oh yeah to jump
into that was yeah it was a lot
you did it though
that is one of the more generous ways to
put it yes i did it
and
slowly rebuilding my body however many
years later
so emerson college studying film yes why
did you choose to study film and
what were the most important things that
perhaps you learned if any and the most
important things that you did not learn
and we could take a piecemeal also we
don't have to answer all of it
i think the story for me is like a lot
of people in creative fields it goes
back you know far beyond college to to
my initial
introduction to school and education and
kind of figuring out that like
my brain style didn't really jive with
what
people were asking me to do
so
the academic
portion of school was always really
difficult for me and then i found art
and so art was always a huge part of my
life
that goes up through high school i was
actually i was originally i was going to
do ceramics i was like headed to alfred
university
and i wanted to do ceramics
and did that a lot in high school and
actually had like pieces in the national
art show and stuff so i'm still pretty
proud of that but at some point i
started doing math and ceramics you know
listen no shade on ceramics and you
climb to the top of that ladder like any
other ladder you can make a lot of money
but you know it's not exactly the best
life plan i guess and the other thing is
i wanted to do something i wanted to be
in a medium that that had power you know
that had power to
tell stories to
to inform people
to
i mean i grew up i grew up with
two
kind of bleeding heart liberal
teachers
in my family and
my mom was a writing teacher and she
focused on
teaching writing through using film so
she was using like pink floyd the wall
deliverance apocalypse now you know
do the right thing deliverance is
intense
yeah exactly right
she was using pretty heavy stuff with
high school students to kind of
grow ideas and to teach critical
thinking and all those things and i
wanted to be okay all right i'm glad you
mentioned the time frame like high
school i'm imagining like teaching
little timmy in third grade how to do
his cursive with deliverance appropriate
yeah yeah no age-appropriate
age-appropriate
i mean kind of age-appropriate i don't
know deliverance like i said i don't
know some high school students maybe
some high school students maybe not but
that introduced me to film and
introduced me to the idea that film
could be more than just
the art form or the the money making
enterprise that it could be you
actually
a way to talk about you know issues that
are going on in our culture a way to
reflect on ourselves as humans
and
i wanted to be a part of telling those
stories so i just pivoted from ceramics
which is the original goal to
filmmaking
i mean i had jaws i love that movie and
i i had jaws on vhs tape i recorded it
off of hbo right
i watched that movie so many times i
broke the vhs tape
so there was like a love for the art
form before i even knew what the art
form was and i wanted to chase that so i
went to emerson it's the only school in
the end it was the only school that i
actually sent an application to they
denied me
and i got in my car because i lived in
new hampshire i got in my car i drove
down to boston and went to the
admissions department why'd you deny me
and they put me in a room and i talked
to someone and at the end of the meeting
she left and she came back in and she
said cool
you want to come to emerson come to
emerson that's incredible i couldn't
believe it
so after the
i can't believe you denied me why'd you
deny me what was there a plan going into
it why do you think they let you in was
it just the sheer fact that you were
there in person and wouldn't leave i
think that's exactly it you know we work
in an industry where like tenacity is
kind of the key ingredient right
i was a total [ __ ] up in so many ways
and i didn't know my ass from my elbow
but
i was i was tenacious enough to go down
there and basically demand that they
save a bed for me i do think in the
meeting at some point i said i said you
better save a bed because i'm showing up
and and i just think she likes that you
know yeah it was great yeah i wish i
knew who that was i wish i knew that
admissions first i
do have to kind of thank them
yeah so yeah they saved me a bed
it was great they read the tea leaves
correctly too
you know in a sense right yeah yeah
definitely a couple uh turns i didn't
expect in the road there but yeah for
sure no no doubt did you learn what you
were hoping to learn in school
i i mean honestly going into college i'm
not even sure i knew what i wanted to
learn
i had like these really weird
conceptions of what the industry was
i i still kind of pictured it as like
i don't know
i i pictured it in terms of
i kind of want to crawl out of my small
town context and live in some
big glitzy kind of space you know and i
think that's what i thought hollywood
was and so like that was that was kind
of the goal originally
and
and you like quickly learn that
that's not really how it rolls
but here's the thing about emerson
college and in like it's it is a really
great school
in a lot of ways they put you they put
you on set and so emerson's kind of
known for building technicians and what
i learned that i don't know that i went
in wanting to learn but was the most
valuable thing is i learned how to be on
set i learned how to use everything on
set i learned how to do everything on
set that's a rarity a lot of film school
is just theory this was like hands-on
and that allowed me to go out and like
actually start doing stuff and little
did i know that my particular little
niche of this industry in the end would
require me to know how to do everything
you know so
i learned that i guess i kind of believe
in that i believe in that aspect of
going to college and
i know there's a lot of people out there
that think you don't have to go to film
school and i guess i would kind of agree
with that too
i think that you can go out and you work
in the industry and you'll learn what
you need to learn
a lot of different ways different paths
to approach it and
post graduation all right so you've
spent three years working for your
mentor director michael mann right
maybe you can for people who have no
context a kind of explain in brief who
michael mann is now
and then
at that time
who michael mann was and how that
actually came to be that you were
working with him
i was extremely lucky because i mean
like literally going out of school i was
like i want to work for michael mann or
terence malik or martin scorsese it was
like
this thing just fell into my lap who who
michael is is and i think the most
important thing to note about who he is
and who he was then is michael was one
of the few like truly powerful directors
that was left in hollywood there's
obviously a few now but the kind of the
the age of of the peck and paws
using these incredibly powerful
juggernaut
directors is kind of like come and gone
what is peckinpause i don't know what
that is oh like like sam pacompa is like
a very famous director think of like the
wild bunch yeah okay i got it these very
very powerful huge personalities that
can drive a set with
300 extras and
explosions and massive camera teams and
just the big think of the big 70s kind
of films you know and these directors
who
were so just so big and so powerful that
they could drive all of that well
michael was that and even at the time
that i started working for him which was
in 2000
and so he still had the the power to
to go against the studio right to say
like no this is when you say power i'd
love to hear you elaborate on that does
it like in in terms of like leverage
because of past performance
just sheer personality and
stubbornness where people will fold and
allow him to do what he wants to do
i i don't i'd love to hear you yeah
describe a little bit all of those
things and i mean i think what he did
really well and was really smart about
was he always had the talent on his side
actors felt safe with him
his track record was
obviously just incredible i mean you
think of a film like the insider and
what he was able to do with
russell crowe who's obviously a
brilliant actor but like
look at that character in the insider
and look at what michael was able to
build
and so he had the trust of of actors and
when you have the trust of actors at
that level and the actors are like
people like russell crowe and
will smith and
tom cruise you have a lot of power so
that's one thing he had
but he also and i think this is like a
thing that people don't understand a lot
about directing it's like
it takes a level of of discipline and
drive and energy and fortitude
that is that is not within the scope of
normal human existence to make these
films to pilot a
150 million dollar film a 200 million
dollar film
to be in charge of something that is so
big and so sweeping and epic and i i
worked with michael on the on the making
of ali
right so we were what i think 130
something like that was the end budget
but we had nights i mean we had a night
in mozambique where we had 15 000 extras
yeah and think about that
and he's at the helm of all that and he
has to hold all that together and he has
to keep focused keep straight keep drive
keep the actors in there keep the crew
in there
all of that stuff that takes a truly
unique person usually takes a total
[ __ ] tyrant as well yeah and he would
fall into that category also
those
kind of directors are kind of less and
less because the studios
the studios have quite a bit of control
now right and so
the studio it's it's more kind of
decision by committee now yeah you know
you have very powerful studio heads you
have very powerful
executive producers within the studios
and so i think that there's fewer and
fewer of the directors
i mean i guess paul thomas anderson
would be like a modern kind of example
of this who can go in and say like this
is the film this is the story this is my
vision this is what we're gonna execute
and you're not gonna [ __ ] touch it
yeah and that's rare and michael had
that how did you
get the job with michael and actually
two questions maybe we can back up so so
you said i want to work for
michael mann a name i didn't recognize
or martin scorsese terence malik who is
terence malik and why those three in
your mind terence malik is thin red line
and he just has a way of making these
incredibly articulate films that almost
feel like
visual poems you know but a very
powerful director and someone who was
able to really exercise
the
the medium of film and like use all of
all of the tools and spend like
i mean
this anyone who works in the industry
will know how hard it is to get 45
seconds of silence into a
into a film or into a television show or
into everything where you can just
absorb the natural space or absorb the
characters going through something or
it's like you constantly need to be
packing action and you constantly need
to be packing information you constantly
need to be feeding and feeding and
feeding right and what i really loved
about his films like if you watch his
films he has these beautiful
little detailed nuanced moments
you know within the film that
just hard to achieve i mean martin
scorsese is martin scorsese he directed
probably the greatest american film ever
made which is good fellas i believe
i think it was tony's favorite as well
it's
i agree with him it's a masterpiece and
then but michael i really i loved
insider and i loved heat
and i love i think that the last
sequence in last of the mohicans ugh
yeah is
one of the masterpieces of of filmmaking
it's it's technically perfect
i just rewatched last the mohigans
recently because i read the book for the
first time and oh that's cool yeah it
was isn't it amazing it's just
incredible so that's michael you know so
michael did last the mohicans and
it's a it's a good film i like i like
the rest of the film but from the moment
that they leave the village where they
burn the i forget his name the british
soldier
and he chases them up into the hills
yeah it's
it's perfect it's perfect he doesn't
miss a beat and that it's beautifully
really beautifully conceived and
beautifully shot and also creatively
deviates from the book and a bunch of
really interesting ways and so at some
point i would love to talk to like the
screenwriter and i mean this is a
fantasy right sit at dinner have some
wine with like the screenwriter michael
be like
i know it was a long time ago but let's
talk about it all right so
how did you get the job with michael
it's totally random i just got i got a
phone call one day what
well why did they know who the hell you
were because i it was easy i got a call
from someone
who i had known at emerson right and it
just said hey they need a temporary
office assistant for three days i can't
take the job it's michael mann's office
do you want to do it i was like keep
[ __ ] kidding yeah absolutely
and i got in that office and i look back
now and i'm like they must all thought
it was just totally out of my mind but
like i didn't i didn't leave
i forgot what i left i left at like 11
30 at night or something i stayed i like
stayed after i like cleaned the whole
copy room i organized the fridge i like
i just did anything i could i was like
i'm doing anything i can to stay in this
office yeah and i did and at the end of
the three days
they're like yeah we got a film coming
up do you would you want to be a pa on
the phone of course
so i took that
wow where it really turned though is
that michael had an assistant and i was
there and i was like the runner and
the office lackey
but but i knew i knew stuff like because
of emerson like i said i i knew how to
run cameras i knew how to run systems i
knew how to do a lot of stuff and i had
a solid
base of understanding filmmaking right
and and the other thing i did is when i
got in there i i asked for the research
material and they so like hey read this
book read this book read this book and i
just went and read them all
and so i knew how to do all these things
and eventually i'd start you know i
started setting up the rentals on
cameras and stuff like that right
and then you know they're video cameras
none of these cats know how to use them
these older filmmaking cats you know
like michael and his generation they
didn't
look at a video camera it's like they
had no idea what to do with these things
so he's like oh you know how to run it
and i'm like yeah i know to run all this
stuff you know and he's like okay come
down to the gym where we're training
with will and you can help me set these
things up and stuff like that so i would
basically just set these cameras up and
hand them to michael
and and every once in a while i'll
lift my head up and be like oh my god
i'm standing in a room with
will smith and michael mann and
then eventually
ali came by and like hanging out with
ali and then darius kanji who's a very
famous cinematographer who's there and i
remember one day darius kanji who i was
like these cats are like my idols when
i'm in film school right darius kanji
shot delicatessen
like
darius kanji came up to me he's like
he's like hey man he's like
don't tell anyone but i have no idea how
to use this camera i'm like
okay cool but like dial it in for him
i'm like you're all good man just ask me
by doing that stuff and reading the
research material like eventually
michael kind of pulled me more and more
in and then i remember one night
i still feel kind of bad for this kid
but it was such a bad call he had this
assistant and the assistant went to a
roger waters concert and left me alone
with him i'm like dude you just
you just left fox in the hen house man
like you closed the door behind you like
i am going to [ __ ] destroy you so i
stayed and
i stayed and eventually michael comes
out and he's like he's like where's you
know so and so
and i'm like oh he went to a concert and
he's like oh he went to a concert i was
like yeah yep i'm here and he's like
yeah but you don't know any of the stuff
he's like i need this quote from the
david remnick book and i was like
actually i read that book and i know
right where that quote is and i'll get
it for you right now and i went down and
made the photocopy and i don't know a
week later that kid's moving his [ __ ]
out of his desk and i'm moving into it
and it was that cold
and i went on this uh incredible ride
with him wow
i was going to ask you i was going to
ask you how the research materials came
in couple months after
africa
wow so from the three-day office
assistant yeah that has to be a world
world record pole vault
into like
a whole different stratosphere of
responsibilities that's just incredible
i mean what a story
that was amazing it was amazing and he
handed me also like being his assistant
he handed me responsibility over all the
creative materials so
listen i i michael's he's a very very
difficult person he can be cruel
he can be incredibly cold to people who
have been
loyal to him for years there's a lot of
ugliness there and a lot of stuff that
eventually i was like you know i don't
want to be that kind of person and i
still feel that way but i can't you
can't but respect him to the
highest degree as as a creative i've
never seen someone with so much creative
energy and so much drive it was like all
of a sudden just being in a different
universe
where
i at 24
was using every ounce of energy i had to
keep up with this man who was 60.
[Laughter]
that's the difference that's the
difference you know with someone like
him
but he handed me this like he would keep
these running
notes that were
thousands of pages long these huge
volumes huge three-ring binders
where
he had thousands of pages of of creative
notes that he had made on every scene
and he handed me responsibility for all
that stuff and so a lot of what i was
doing was
like a look into someone who's operating
at the very highest level who's arguably
a master of their craft it was
incredible i mean it was it was amazing
and i was next to him for every second
of it
that's incredible
the research material so i see how the
research materials ended up being
helpful did you request the research
materials because you thought
there might be an opening like that or
was there a different reason for you
requesting i was like i have a foothold
here and i am going to live and breathe
whatever i can that this man lives and
breathes and i'm good just because i'm
here and i'm 24 and i got
just like full of energy i do think that
they probably thought i was a
like a speed freak though i think they
probably thought i was like either a
coke head or a speed freak i wasn't but
i was just so charged up and so full of
energy that i
just did all these things yeah just
total immersion it was amazing
how did television
enter
the fray so to speak how did you then
become involved with television that was
the weird thing it's like
my career took a very
a very weird kind of turn there like i i
finished working for michael what i had
done while i was with him they they
handed me a video camera because they're
like well you're here for everything so
just keep the camera on you film what
you can
in terms of like a behind the scenes
type of thing exactly i ended up filming
quite a bit of that and they were
producing a documentary for hbo on the
making of the film
and it ended up being that 50 of the
footage and the end result was mine
which film was this just uh you may have
already mentioned ali oh that was ali
yeah that was the film the film was ali
yep
and so
i had filmed all this stuff they ended
up using a lot of it the producer came
up to me and she said hey listen we get
a lot of footage from assistants and
it's it always sucks your footage is
actually really good we use quite a bit
of it but you might think about this as
this is a skill you have
at the same time
you know
young in hollywood
there's a lot of temptation
i might need you to elaborate on that
what does that mean just the vices of
hollywood
in the end i got pretty deep on just
alcohol and partying and
a lot of stuff gotta like caught a dui
broke up with my
girlfriend at the time
stopped working for michael
things just kind of fell apart a little
bit but i always had the camera you know
and so i ended up where i ended up like
and picture this i'm like one day i'm
flying around in gulfstream fives with
michael and will smith and
i had dinner at [ __ ] nelson mandela's
house in mozambique like picture that
you know 24 hanging out with nelson
mandela
quick interjection correct me if i'm
wrong so you grew up partially at least
in west virginia in an old farmhouse
with no electricity am i making that up
or is that legitimate that's true that's
true when i was much younger though yeah
so i'm just painting the contrast since
you're mentioning flying around on a g5
it's a good thing to paint because west
virginia comes full circle in this story
of my life too
so west virginia that still has a place
in my heart i'll elaborate on that in a
bit
so
so yeah one day i'm flying around in
gulfstream and you know hanging out with
nelson mandela and the next day i'm like
in my parents basement back in the
middle of winter in new hampshire like a
broke ass bombed out alcoholic like dude
you got to put your life back together
and and so i ended up
teaching a film class for my dad who ran
summer programs at this private school
that i grew up at
and saved up enough money to buy a
camera and then i just started shooting
from the very bottom you know and i just
started again
what did you start shooting what did you
start shooting i was literally shooting
like america's most fantabulous homes
and stuff like that
were you finding the gigs in new york or
how did you find the gigs at that point
again my friend
the same friend that i shot the
documentary on the football team with
my buddy todd lubin reached out to me
and and there's a number of times in my
career and in my life that todd
reached out to me and was like hey
you should come do this a couple of
life-changing kind of moments
so he reached out he hooked me up with
these gigs you know making not much
money i didn't have a license i lived in
new hampshire most of the jobs are in
new york i'd have to like
take a bus to like
south station in boston with all my
equipment and all these huge pelican
cases get on the train go down to new
york shoot these things get back
i was hustling yeah and eventually
rebuilt it and you know how it is
you get better and better projects you
get kind of known for things you meet
people your network starts to spread
the time with michael is almost like an
appetizer like an amuse boosh you know
and and then the real work came of
building something from this from
scratch again yeah building from the
bottom but that taught me that taught me
how to be tough and it taught me how to
shoot and it taught me how to be scrappy
and most of all and the thing that ended
up paying off the most when i got down
the road with tony and stuff is learned
how to make something out of nothing you
know because you're like with michael
and on the projects like that you get
all these resources huge budgets yeah
like you know huge huge stuff
when you're working on the kind of stuff
that i do
it's a knife fight you're intentionally
small you don't operate with big crews
you operate with small crews you don't
want to freak people out i don't work
with actors i work with people
you gotta you gotta have a light touch
you gotta go in you gotta figure out how
to pull the most
value out of out of things
with the fewest amount of resources yeah
totally
how did you and then end up connecting
with
chris and lydia at zpz
again in in kind of working my way back
up through the ranks by like 2000 and
[Music]
i guess 2006
i
shot this show in buffalo
called tough love it was like it was a
dark
romantic comedy about a matchmaker set
in buffalo
i lived in buffalo for six months in the
winter which is i i mean hats off to
anyone in buffalo you are you are tough
people
and the dp on that show was someone
named zack zamboni who is
absolutely just a phenomenal gifted
dp
who understands this genre
better than anyone else i know when i
say this genre i mean like the verite
documentary
right genre he ended up giving my name
to chris and lydia because he had been
working for them and was at that time
working for tony on no reservations
they hired me for a couple of jobs and
and that's how i got in with them and
and so i owe a tremendous amount to zach
i still talk to him all the time as much
as possible and
yeah he's he's
uh what can you say about him he's the
pastor sounds like a mensch too along
with
along with todd
yeah
question about working your way back up
so if we do now just a mini flashback
yeah
you're taking uh
all sorts of different projects anything
okay so anything whatever you can get
however
you i know you're also a very smart guy
one could say what happened with michael
mann was one part luck but it was also
many other
required many other ingredients for that
to actually coalesce into what it did
as you are working your way back up was
there any particular strategy about how
let's say past the halfway point before
you get to zpz about how you chose
projects or anything like that or was it
really just throw as much against the
wall and hope there's some synchronicity
let's definitely throw as much against
the wall as possible but i think that i
think that a marker of many people's
careers is certainly not you know not
like my philosophy or anything like that
but like kind of like i don't know like
a trapdoor spider or something you know
you sit there you're kind of like
patient you're grinding out the days
when the cricket comes by you grab it
and that's the moment when the assistant
goes to the concert
gotcha come on dude
come on man like i mean rules of
engagement that's legitimate that is a
terminal move that he made i i i agree i
mean who does he think he's working for
it was stunning to me that he allowed
that opening yeah and for roger waters
which like respect but
it's not pink floyd yeah yeah
i think that it's just knowing those
moments and like there are
career-changing moments and it's
sometimes just a phone call it's like
out of the blue and you're like oh this
is the moment this is the thing this is
the project when i got turned on to cpz
and chris and lydia that was like very
clearly it and i and i was very aware of
tony and no reservations at that point
and was like that is what i want to do i
want to do that you know and so when
they came into the picture i was like oh
you i mean yeah
i'm gonna do anything that it takes put
me on any project you want and i will
prove to you
i deserve to be on that ride
and and working with tony and that's
what i tried to do so how did you go
about trying to do it what did the first
first date look like
first thing i did for them was show for
pbs called diary of a foodie
which was a great show it was a
beautiful show and so
you know what did i do i
show up on time work your ass off shoot
good footage don't be a pain in the ass
keep your head low
[Music]
figure out the lay of the land don't
come in like you own the place i don't
know the basics
yeah
luckily learned how to do that [ __ ] from
my dad you know they taught me how to
work hard
and so like when the opportunity and i
don't think that i've been like someone
in
my
career i mean there are people a lot of
people in this industry that are like
just way more
calculated and machiavellian about how
they
go about they see it way way down the
road they know where they're headed they
know the strategy to get there
that's impressive to me i can't do that
i see the thing come i grab it you know
and like that's what happened with that
i knew that i wanted to work with tony i
saw a window and i just was not gonna
leave
so i guess that's it same thing with
showing up at emerson and telling them
that i'm coming regardless of whether
they have a bed for me or not i guess
part of what prompted me to reach back
out
and i think i said this and the text
was i had an international flight
and
i watched road runner this documentary
about anthony bourdain
tony bourdain and
i thought it was to the extent that i
could even assess it because i i didn't
know him
but i thought it was well done it wasn't
it didn't seem one-dimensional in the
sense that they
they they really approached it from many
different perspectives i would be
curious to know what you thought was
if you have any opinion like what you
thought was important for them to
include that they included and then
perhaps what you would have liked to
have seen more of
or mentioned
i'm stoked to talk about roadrunner we
should back up at some point on the zpz
stuff because there's a there's a bunch
of stuff that happened in between there
which is steve
and we should talk about steve oh yeah
we're definitely going to do that
roadrunner
it was directed by morgan neville who's
one of the great documentary filmmakers
out there right now
and what i would say about road runner
and a lot of different people like
by the way i should specify it like
there were a lot of people that worked
for tony and and a lot of people that
were really close with him it is in no
way am i
like the person or
a singular kind of thing there
there was a lot of people that were
really close to tony
it went on the ride with him
and i'm sure a lot of them have
different opinions about about
roadrunner for me
when i watch the film and i've only seen
it once
i may only ever see it once you know
it's it's hard it's hard for me to watch
it again
what i saw
i think did what they did was as good a
job as you could do
with that subject
without having been on the inside of it
yeah which i guess is in some ways i
mean that in is as kind of the greatest
compliment i can give
because i think that there were things
that were
missed but i think that there are things
that you kind of had to really be there
and know him and have gone through that
experience
to really you know to really fully grasp
and understand and i think they did a
really good job of of
getting who he was and getting what that
journey was
and as far as things i wish they had
leaned into more and away from more i i
do wish they had gotten a little bit
more of
who tony was
in terms of his relationship to
to people in the way he approached
people the way he approached the world
yes he was he was a a champion of the
underdog and they mentioned that in the
film but
it was it was more than that like tony
really really deeply felt
i think a connection to
to people whose environments he was
walking into and he felt that connection
as a guest
but
he was the kind of person who would like
wade into a room and
pick up a baby and you know sit
in someone's living room and really
actually
kind of be there you know
and be with them and be
with them on their like on their terms
and that was one of kind of the
intangibles about him yeah he was a very
connected person to the world for
someone who is like as
strangely agoraphobic
as he was he had an amazing ability to
be truly like connected and in the
moment and see the beauty
in
things that are often passed up
and to see the like the beauty in people
and in the small nuances and details of
their life and
i don't know i guess so i guess that a
little more of that and a little less of
the kind of
whodunit aspect of tony's suicide you
know
i understand going down that road for
sure and like i and who am i to talk i
contributed as much to that as anyone
else through my interview you know but
it is not the defining characteristic of
who tony was there's there are so many
others that
that i that i feel could have
i guess played a little bigger
yeah makes sense it's well done though
and and we'll we'll certainly come back
to tony
so you mentioned
zpz let's talk about zpz
and steve
so who is steve and and what do these
chapters look like
so i came in on foodies
and then did a couple of no reservations
with tony and
those were great so i i the first one i
got called to replace someone on the
egypt show
with tony and i got along with him which
was kind of amazing and i guess i didn't
know at the time i didn't know it was
anything special but i got a call after
from lydia and she's like he knows your
name this is a benchmark moment i was
like oh okay cool so i went to egypt
with them in
and we had a great show i did a few
other no reservations was like getting
to know tony but then they called me i
was working at the time again for my
buddy todd
who was show running biggest loser
and i had shot 96 episodes the biggest
loser which is uh real formatty reality
tv with a little more puking than normal
reality tv
but i'd done that for three years and
really i learned like how to shoot on
that thing because you're just grinding
out like you have a camera on your
shoulder for like 10 hours a day and you
are just grinding out like shooting you
know it's the same stuff over and over
again but you're like
you'll really learn it
i got a call and they're like we have
this guy
steve ranella who like
he's got a really interesting story he's
like he lives in brooklyn but he hunts
for his food
he's a conservationist and a hunter and
a writer and he's a really smart guy and
you should meet him i think he'd get
along with him and
so i i go and meet steve in a parking
lot in michigan and within 35 minutes i
am
this deep in a swamp you know up to my
shoulders in a swamp holding the camera
above my head as steve sets turtle traps
and it was just like this moment of like
oh my god this is this is it because
this is like super experiential it's
super visual he's incredibly smart just
a fountain of information as you know
from hanging out with him it's like it
never stops yeah
encyclopedic
it's just unbelievable and so it had all
of everything was there you got all of
the information you got something that's
really smart you got a philosophy behind
it that makes sense
and yet you're doing stuff that's highly
physical that's really cinematic that's
really kind of gripping and and kind of
hits on like a root human level you're
out like
doing it you're not like getting food
you know
so i
met him in that swamp and just started
like a journey with him we went on to
film
eight episodes of a show called wild
within
which was
i think like a early attempt to make a
hunting show and figure out like what a
hunting show could be in terms of also
telling a story and having a narrative
progression
but some of it was really unique in that
we were just actually doing
the stuff that we said we were gonna do
i i remember early on like a a producer
came on they're like okay where's the
line item for the animal wrangler it
seems like [ __ ] animal wrangler it's
like there's no animal regular dude he's
like we're going to alberta to hunt
moose he's like
and he's like well how do you know
you're going to be successful he's like
i don't
it's hunting we don't know if we're
gonna be successful who's dropping off
the moose no one's dropping off the
moose to present that to a network and
feel like well how are you gonna assure
us that you come up with something here
we're not you know we're gonna go out
and actually do it that was that was a
lot for a network to get their heads
around but it allowed us to to be
genuine about what we were doing
you know and i i really believe like
when you watch these shows
people know they know when they're being
bullshitted and they know when it's
honest you know the [ __ ] is fun to
watch i get it it draws numbers and
people enjoy it
but if you want to build a legacy you
want to build one of these legacy shows
you got to be honest with your audience
that's what they will come back for year
after year after year that's what
they're they're they're looking for
and that's what steve provided and so we
went and we did this show that was
really unique and i felt like we had
moments that were
were unlike anything i had ever seen on
tv before we're like i mean we're in it
man hunting pigs in hawaii
having the pigs like
run up this [ __ ] and get in this
little they got in this little stream
there where we found them they're like
in a fight to the death with the dogs
that that had had run them down steve's
like in there with a knife trying to
stab pig and not dog
blood screaming there's
mud and [ __ ] flying all over the place
and
i know that that can be very difficult
for some people to hear and understand
but for me i had this moment where i was
like well i feel incredibly connected to
like the human experience to
the natural experience i feel like
a part of kind of the whole dynamic and
you know
we ate pig and we used all of it and we
were responsible about it and
so i could kind of from a philosophical
standpoint i felt like i could get my
head around it and understand
oh this is why this person does this
had you ever hunted prior to that show
or been involved with hunting
not at all never i like what i realized
is like growing up in new hampshire i
felt like i was outdoorsy and then i
went with steve to alaska and i was like
oh i'm not outdoorsy at all
i've never been off a trail i've never
been off like a like a well-marked trail
you know
uh and all of a sudden you're standing
in the middle of like
prince of wales island with steve it's
[ __ ] pouring rain you're freezing
cold you're cliff hung
because
because it's steve
and something always happens
wait what do you mean by cliffhang what
does that mean
what is cliffhang cliffhanging it
usually happens when you're descending
right but basically you're say you're
descending through heavy cover
and you get out to a cliff right
and you make a decision which is like i
can get down this thing and you go down
a drop that you can't come back up and
then you realize that the drop the next
drop isn't 15 feet at 60 feet
then you're cliffon oh [ __ ]
that sounds that sounds like a great
situation yeah and you got to figure it
out you know but it was but figuring all
that stuff out was like was incredible
because i i again just i was just like
i'm just a dude i didn't
come from any kind of special background
not a green beret you know
i was dropped into this thing with no
understanding of what my capacities were
when i was put into an environment where
you have to rely on like your natural
instincts and your ability to do [ __ ]
your ability to like not get yourself
[ __ ] killed you know when you're out
in the woods and at first i was like i
can't do this i can't do this and um and
by the way i've got a 50 pound pack on
in a camera all the time
so i got one hand everyone else got two
hands
at first it was terrifying i remember
that first time we got a little bit
cliff hung and i'm like i'm like where's
the sat phone let's call the coast guard
yeah and they're like they're like dude
we don't call the coast guard over this
trust me you're gonna be okay it and it
was an incredible an incredible
realization to be like oh wait i am
gonna be okay i've got all the all the
stuff is innate in being human that i
need to like survive this
and to figure it out and to deal with it
whereas
i think a lot of my career up to that
point had been like how to navigate the
human world and
be kind of a player in all of that the
constructed world yeah that's right i
had never connected with the natural
world and i had no idea that within me
and within all of us was this ability
to navigate the natural world by simply
connecting with stuff that we are born
with yeah and steve steve brought that
out of me and once i realized that
then the whole world opened and you're
like oh my god i'm in the middle of this
highly dynamic highly visual thing that
we can just run with and we can like no
one's
i don't want to say no one's ever done
that style
of production before but truthfully
honestly in the hunting world they did a
lot of like
and you know what it is they they sit in
a blind they shoot
a bear over a 55-gallon drum of donuts
you know i i find all that [ __ ]
disgusting they they won't even like a
lot of these shows won't even finish the
episode unless they get a good kill shot
and we were like [ __ ] kill shots i don't
give a [ __ ] about the kill shot yeah we
were doing something that just felt so
raw and real and unproduced and
unscripted
that it was very refreshing and once
kind of figured out
oh this you put your feet here you walk
this way you hold the camera like this
this is how you don't get yourself
killed this is how you don't get
yourself hurt
once we figured all that [ __ ] out or
once i figured all that [ __ ] out then
you were left with just this incredible
canvas to paint on and i think we did
something really special i think we
really put people
in that sensory environment what it
feels like to be out there and to be a
predator and to be
part of this whole
dynamic that's always going on around us
but that we have largely
excised ourselves from
and we were there with a camera to
capture it
i'll be the the first to
concur that steve is is
as legit as i've seen certainly having
spent time with him for one episode yeah
in the in the brooks range
which was incredible yeah you got thrown
into the deep end oh that was that was
exciting yeah having the baron baron
ground grizzlies charging the camp
oh my god and steve i remember when uh
when one charged the camp and it's
running because
giannis spotted it yeah wait giannis is
that is that right am i getting his name
right that's correct yeah yeah yeah so
yanus nickname the bear whisperer
i think on that trip
ended up at some point he was just
unpacking some gear or something and
then he kind of sat up and he's like
wait a second grabbed his binoculars and
then lo and behold he spotted this bear
that was on its hind legs smelling some
of our
uh meat yeah and it just comes
galloping that's probably not the right
term but like loping towards us around
barreling is usually the way i feel
about bears barreling
yeah barreling that's yes absolutely
barreling and i remember
steve
is being summoned right we're all like
steve steve because half of us are
muggles who have never dealt with bears
before
and steve comes out of his tent and he's
so pissed off
because he had
he had left his cell phone in the corner
of his tent and this mosquito kind of
deet
liquid had pooled in that side and
destroyed his cell phone and so he's
like
ranting and raving and [ __ ] this and
[ __ ] that and he's so pissed as this
bear is running he's completely
unconcerned and we're all like uh steve
bear uh steve bear steve bear
and you know eventually he's like yeah
yeah yeah yeah he like shoots a shotgun
in the air and like waves at it and it
runs off and like
turns around a quarter mile away and
just sits there staring at us and i'm
like now now what do i do
but he is uh he is absolutely 100
absolutely
able to walk the talk in every part of
that story including him destroying his
cell phone it rings so true to steve
but
that's exactly right i mean he you to be
with steve varnell is to you're with
someone who is so
so sure-footed and so competent in their
environment
it is something it is really something
to behold and he kind of shrugs it off
when you try to compliment him but
that is one of the toughest smartest
most solid people i've ever met in my
life you know yeah
i just can't say enough about uh about
who's he is i was just gonna add
incredible human and also for those
people who are like oh isn't that the
hunting guy on tv he is also an
incredibly
talented and not just talented because
that kind of infers he's born with it
out of the box maybe some of that is
true but
skillful writer i mean american buffalo
excellent many other books
excellent writer that's earned
i mean sure like born with a
predilection for writing sure i'm sure
that's true but
he's a writer i mean he writes
from nine in the morning to five in the
afternoon every day
he
he does the job and and it has made him
a great writer and i would say that his
voiceover and his writing is some of the
best in the industry he's he's just
excellent
and his built that that initial show
wild within went on i mean of course it
was canceled in the first season because
like no network was ever going to be
able to really wrap their head around
what we were doing
and so we launched a self-financed
endeavor which was meat-eater which is
now grown into this big company that
steve owns
or partially owns or whatever i don't
know exactly what the ownership
structure is but it's grown into this
big thing that was
when we did when we actually went out
and did that that was like the fully
formed version of the show i feel like
wild within we were just kind of like
learning how to be outside and how to
make tv and how to not [ __ ] people
and trust me we did a little bit a
little bit of eye rolling [ __ ] and
and wild within but by the time we got
to meat eater we weren't bullshitting
anymore we were just going out and doing
it and grinding and we got really good
at it and i just have watched recent
episodes now and they're beautiful and
smart and
just just excellent high quality tv and
like very very proud of that that that
something i was involved in like on that
ground level has has maintained that
kind of quality is like incredibly
rewarding
what do you feel like aside from
what we've already discussed
what skills did you develop or what did
you learn from that show that ex that
experience on the show
that has ended up
transferring to other things helping
with other things later
the psychological game is everything i
think we have a tendency
to
to shut down when we feel defeated or to
shut down when
we feel like
like we've reached an impasse you know
and
what's amazing about being in the
natural environment like that and and
really doing it is that you're forced to
face
the landscape you're forced to face
the elements you're forced to face
weather you're forced to face all these
things that are incongruous with
producing television and achieving your
goal and and you don't have the option
because you're out alone i mean you know
you know how it i mean from the bricks
range show you know from the character
you get dropped off by like a piper cub
in the middle of nowhere and they're not
coming back for 10 days or however long
you were out
and so you got to figure all that [ __ ]
out in between
and yeah we go out with like a lot of
tools and stuff but it's hard not to
feel defeated when you're when you're
freezing when you're soaking wet when
you roll out of your sleeping bag in the
morning and the reality you're facing is
you got to put on
your soaking wet
wool
under clothes that have been out in
you know
40 degree weather all night and and it's
gonna suck and it's gonna hurt and it's
gonna be
miserable and cold and depressing
and
you gotta push through that anyways
i think for me and i don't know that
this is the same for everyone else you
know but i think for me that was the
greatest thing
that i took away from that is like
keeping your head space keeping your
mood elevated keeping the possibility of
something amazing and beautiful and
brilliant happening
and keeping grinding is the way to
to do this specific line of work because
we don't get to we again we don't have
the resources to control all the
variables and we're working with real
people in all the work that i do
so you're kind of at the whim of a lot
of dynamics and you got to learn how to
see
the things that get in your way as gifts
you know you got to learn how to take
them and operate around them and move
off of them and and use them
and that's what that's what i learned
out there
with steve
so let's try a segue
into
the world of tony
and this may or may not make sense as a
segue but let's let's try it and then we
can go anywhere you want to go
the first time working with tony in
egypt
because this this is sort of the what
was the term you used
like a trap spider moment of sorts for
you
that definitely was okay so let's have
you describe what happened in egypt
so i got the call i was waiting for
which was
hey you know one of the shooters can't
go to egypt
i think he got sick or something and do
you have is your passport up to date can
you go like next week
and i was like you know absolutely
you know i'm there's no way i'm missing
that so
i
went to egypt i kind of jumped in you
know that that show had been going
already for a while and so they had
ways of doing things tried to do my best
to assimilate to the ways they were
doing things and bring what i could to
the table but
the thing that changed it all and like
tony
tony was tony was not like everyone that
came in the door was like hey how's it
going you know he's
he plays it cool and and the other thing
is if he doesn't like you you are just
simply not going anywhere on that show
and there's a lot of people he didn't
like you know yeah he had pretty
particular i think if you were honest i
think if you weren't addicted to people
i think that if you carried yourself
in a respectable manner i think that if
you if you saw that you worked hard and
i think that if you saw that you could
like hang out and like
i have to admit there was a lot of
drinking on the show if you could hang
out and not become just like a sloppy
drunk
then you were kind of cool and you could
hang out but initially he wasn't going
to give you anything the thing that
changed it for me with with tony was we
were going out we were going to go out
and spend a night out in the western
desert with the bedouin
and
and we go we drive you know a few hours
outside of cairo we meet them
in the desert and you're like on a paved
road with just
sand on both sides
we meet this group of bedouin all in
their
like late 70s toyota land cruisers which
is the car of choice in the western
desert of egypt
and we're just gonna go drive off into
the desert and i was like well okay so
we're driving across the desert i should
get up on the roof of one of these cars
and just film a bunch of car to car
stuff
we're driving across the desert how like
how bad can it be
and so
five minutes later we're going like 80
miles an hour across the desert i am
absolutely terrified
of one hand on the camera and my other
arm my right arm was around a four-post
bed that for some reason they had
strapped to the
roof of the car
and so i have my arm right now by
four-post bed this is like a bed with a
huge canopy above it is that what you
mean like one of those things yeah and
it was broken down into pieces
they had broken it down into the pieces
and strapped it to the roof of the car i
think that they thought that tony would
want to sleep in a fourth post bed like
out in the desert which is absurd
you know and like tony if you know tony
like all tony wants to do is go off and
like pass out in the sand you know yeah
anyways they had this ridiculous thing
on top of the car and it saved my life
because i was able to hold on to the car
i this whoever the driver was must have
been like i am going to show this white
boy you know and and so they go
barreling off across the desert and
and it is harrowing and i see tony
looking out the window with this
big ridiculous grin looking at me and
like oh yeah look at the new guys suffer
you know like this is this is great i
got great footage and also
what i think did it for me is i by the
time we got to camp i had a
hematoma the size of like a small nerf
football on my bicep where i was holding
on
there was like deep purple where i'd
been holding that's how hard i was
holding on to this thing and that's the
kind of beating that it took up there
and i think that that act of he's like
oh this is a cat who's likes it i mean
i'm a physical shooter you know this is
a cat that's going to throw himself
completely into this and it's like a
light switch went off i landed in camp
he's like hey all right
that was a pretty rough ride i was like
oh yeah look at this i showed him the
bruise and
from that moment on tony liked me i got
called after that
like i said lydia was like this is a
benchmark moment he actually knows your
name after one show
do you want to come back you want to do
another i was like i'll do as many as i
can for as long as i can and that's what
i did so that was the introduction to
tony it just took a act of
i don't know i didn't have kids at the
time so i don't consider it too selfish
but i wouldn't i wouldn't recommend it
to any young shooters
what were some other
pivotal moments or episodes for you
with with tony
i'm thinking
one and we could do something
chronologically that happens sooner but
you like ethiopia ethiopia was huge yeah
we could jump into that if you want to
just describe yeah so when i came on the
show i was just a camera operator
and then worked my way up where i was
like the lead camera and a dp on the
show
and then
i was like if i don't
if i don't
take the opportunity to try to direct
this show
and produce this show and do everything
that i can on this show i'm gonna regret
it
and so around i guess it was around like
2014
i started asking and being like i really
want to direct
the show
and i did a season of mind of a chef
with magnus nielsen in sweden which was
a show that tony produced that allowed
me to really like showcase like hey i
can go out there i can make up eight
episodes i can like lead a show i can
get it done
and it turned out really well partly
because magnus is like a
absolute genius and one of the most
fascinating people you can hang out with
he's like on that he's like with steve
yeah just an incredibly dynamic person i
mean someone who had created like one of
the best restaurants in the world out of
a what was a moose fondue restaurant in
central sweden imagine imagine what he
started with
created one of the best restaurants in
the world by his mid-20s that and was
already a master psalm at that point so
you know that's who magnus nelson is
yeah that is
incredible
but i did that tony saw it tony liked it
and agreed to let me direct and it was
ethiopia
with marcus samuelson so if you know
marcus
i know of him i don't know him
personally personally but certainly know
of him
marcus is on tons of cooking shows you
know he's he's a incredibly magnanimous
huge smile wonderful person tons of
energy
but marx's story is that he was born in
ethiopia and
his during a
oh god i want to say it was a cholera
outbreak it was an infectious disease
outbreak in ethiopia
tuberculosis tuberculosis
and marx's mother
walked he and his sister when they were
just
little little kids
something like 75 miles from her village
into addis and got them to an orphanage
and then died
and so marcus and his sister were
adopted and grew up in sweden
so this was this show was his return to
ethiopia and he had been there before
but like it was also his wife maya
who's just an absolutely incredible
person
and just simply one of the most gorgeous
human beings you'll ever meet
was also from garage and from
one of the more prominent tribes in
ethiopia and so it was a return to her
village it was a return to find his
his his father and reconnect with his
father
it was a big show and i was
i was
terrified
i don't even i don't even know why it
seems irrational at this point but it
was it was i was totally terrified
what were you terrified of i don't know
you know it just
i just respected tony so much i love the
show so much i
you know and i'm someone i
you know i suffer from anxiety disorders
i you know i'm bipolar i you know i have
a few things
in my bag like everyone does to kind of
deal with and it set those off pretty
good but
i went i did it we we had this
incredible show
ethiopia isn't just a totally
extraordinary place like so many places
in
in africa
totally misunderstood one of the more
dynamic environments that you can step
into it's got a
young population there that is just
totally plugged in totally driven super
hard working
now it's one of those places where
you're like man if if the corruption at
the top can ever get out of its own way
these people are going to just kill it
you know
but we yeah it was an it was amazing
experience an amazing experience to like
go and and go back into
maya's home village to find marx's
father
the funniest part of it was
for all the [ __ ] that tony ate through
his career
he is like he just cannot handle
ethiopian food i love ethiopian food of
all things
of all things he said he found his
kryptonite
and so he was basically starving to
death during the show
i'm begging him to eat clif bars and
stuff like that because he wouldn't need
anything
he's just like wasting away
but that was amazing that was the first
show i directed it was like a huge
moment and tony was very kind to me
he gave me the benefit of that
how did you prepare for that and what is
i know this is going to seem like a
really
elementary naive question but yeah
what's the difference
well i've seen you in action
with the camera right and we're going to
talk more about that just because the
the kind of dance involved especially
when you have multiple shooters yeah is
incredible i mean it's it's such
geometry an amazing craft and so much
geometry so we're going to get into that
but
directing in a situation like this
seems to represent
other skill sets that you had not
exercised perhaps as much so how do you
prepare for this you don't seem like the
guy to just wing it
directing is like an interesting word to
use for these because can you typically
think of a director like you're working
in narrative and so you're
you're working with actors you're
working with the crew your
storyboarding it out or whatever that is
a very
very very precise endeavor
this is different
what we do
on these shows is
initially starts with like a ton of
research right so we're just trying to
get our head around the environment
we're trying to understand the dynamics
of what's going on trying to understand
what we can and can't do
and we have to be also in a place like
ethiopia especially you have to be
sensitive to the environment that is a
totalitarian government that is 100
watching everything you do and the
people that we work with there are going
to be left with the repercussions of
what we do and how we behave there right
and so you you know certain things off
the bat where you're like
there's certain stuff that we're not
gonna do there's certain boundaries
we're not gonna try to push and i and i
again hats off to all the people that go
and do do that i hope they do it
carefully and with respect to the people
that they're leaving behind
but
we were going to be very careful going
into an environment like ethiopia
because i don't want to end up that my
pas or my drivers or my fixers is
sitting in some
dingy prison because of something we did
and that's a that's a reality there so
it's going in and assessing what you can
and can't do assessing what the
boundaries are knowing the landscape and
then starting to pull out okay so this
is this very interesting thing there's
this culture of these asmari there and
they are basically
they're basically minstrels right
play this very kind of old-fashioned
kind of music it's kind of like a wrap
where they'll
freestyle stuff from the room they used
to travel around from village to village
but what's really interesting there is
they use the ismari as a way to have
these kind of coded political
discussions right so they have all kinds
of nuance and intricacies in the way
that they do their kind of freestyle rap
that is actually talking about politics
in an environment where you can't talk
about politics right so we know we're
gonna you know this is a cool thing
we're going to do a scene with them okay
where are we going to do that what's
that going to look like so you're
finding different esmari you're looking
at the locations you're pulling people
in okay so we're going to do the ismari
but we need some you know we want to
bring some dancers in there's another
dance troupe over here we can get them
to work together this is a good
environment you know this particular
place to shoot it
what you're actually trying to do is is
set up an environment that is
that is simultaneously
real and authentic
and also
constructed you know yeah and in a way
that we know that the apparatus of
television making is going to work we're
actually going to walk away with
something that works the sound's going
to be workable the lighting is going to
be workable you know we're going to be
able to control the environment and
not have other kinds of
background pollution or
other things that are out of our control
infecting what we're trying to do
i think zach zamboni who i
referenced before said it best when he
said like when we make a show about
vietnam
vietnam doesn't look like that but
vietnam doesn't not look like that
either these are real things but they
are filtered through our process of
trying to set them up in a way where we
can then kind of just give the ship a
little push and hope that it crosses the
lake and that's what we're really trying
to do is pull those elements together
and that's the directing in terms of
like if you're gonna go in and direct
tony like you think you're gonna direct
an actor like that was never gonna
happen you maybe can get him to ask a
couple of questions and if he spends 45
minutes of his hour-long interview
talking about john wick too you're gonna
have to kind of like suck it and deal
with that you know which happens a lot
so like the amount of [ __ ] that i've
heard about john wick it's like i've
never even seen it i i actually won't
watch john wick
because i've heard tony talk about it so
many goddamn times in moments where i'm
like dude i need content here like we're
dying here i don't have anything to put
this scene together and you're talking
about [ __ ] john wick like i won't
watch the movies
and i hear they're great yeah that's
incredible that's basically the process
of what we're doing and then you're
talking to the the dps about how we're
going to shoot it and what style
elements we're going to use what that's
going to look like etc you know and this
was a show where we had a lot of film
references that we were trying to pack
in
what makes someone
a dp
maybe we should also just spell out what
that stands for and
did you interact as a director did you
interact with the dps differently than
most directors interact with dps
definitely i'm sure it drives them crazy
because i have really high expectations
because i was a very accomplished dp
before so a dp is a director of
photography
cinematographer
shooter
kind of go by all those names
i did really well that was my thing i
was really good at it i did really well
and i was i was known
known for it in my again in my little
kind of sub genre
so yeah i interact with the dps
differently because i can see the shots
in it and i have a real advantage in
that
my wife is a director as well she
doesn't come from a cinematography side
so i spend a lot of time working with
her on like how to see things from a
photography standpoint you know and it
gives you a real advantage when you can
it also will drive your [ __ ] dps
crazy because i'm breathing down their
neck all the time i'm like
yeah is that the best shot maybe stand
over there a little bit more you know
move over that way a little bit tighter
you know they're like dude i'm trying to
find it so yeah i think i've probably
ride them a little harder
you know i'm right so it's okay
[Laughter]
most of the time
i'd like to double click on
high standards
because
this is
this is fertile territory for all sorts
of conversations yeah
all right so i want to read
something you can't believe everything
you read on the internet but in the
course of doing research for this
conversation i found something on cnn
and i'm going to read it and then we can
explore it all right what morgan fallon
director cinematographer and producer of
anthony bourdain parts unknown misses
most about working with tony is the
pressure in a recent phone call with cnn
travel fallon described tony's
exceedingly high expectations in awe
indeed he may have been smiling on the
other end of the phone when he explained
the editing process for parts unknown
you could get absolutely gutted in a
rough cut fallon said in other words
bourdain didn't sugarcoat it and this
approach was appreciated by fallon and
other crew members this celebrity chef
and star producer quote was never going
to accept anything mediocre end quote
said fallon who was pleased with the
workflow i felt good when tony was happy
with the show he added and
you know i was i was watching
and we have to spend a ton of time on
this but this dock
that uh in some ways prompted me
reaching out you know road runner
you know tony is so human and so
nuanced and like so loving in so many
ways
and has really [ __ ] high standards
right and i remember at one point when
in that doc they're talking about the
rough cut and they said something like
more than once tony tony told the editor
to like unfuck themselves or something
like that oh we got told to unfuck
ourselves all the time i got told that
on a daily basis
yeah yeah yeah
the mics aren't working unfuck yourself
okay
so so let's talk about different types
of high standards
right like could you elaborate on tony's
particular species of high standards and
if you have any funny stories that's
always great but
you know any any stories that come to
mind are also super helpful and just so
you know where this is going i i'm
wondering like how it contrasts with say
a michael mann or
and i know you i don't think you've had
experience with like james cameron but
like james cameron another person is
really famous for having extremely high
standards
and
you know where the line is between being
like brutally direct
and turning into something else do you
know what i mean yeah i do uh i'd love
to explore that because this is
something i struggle with also so
speaking at the very high end who's
speaking about the michael mann's the
james cameron's the level of expectation
is is
never achievable they will never
it's never good enough
they do not have a level where it's good
enough it can always be better
you have to be that way yes they are
[ __ ] i will say it straight up
michael mann is an [ __ ] and he's
known that way in the industry
but he has to be
that is the only way that you get that
caliber of project done you want to get
through a titanic you are going to have
to be an [ __ ] 100 yeah and the same
is true in in high caliber kitchens
you want to run you want to run a high
caliber kitchen there is only one way to
do it and you are not friends with your
crew
you are you are in charge and it's your
responsibility and and i think that tony
tony approached it from that
from that perspective
at least initially
he had extremely high expectations that
i think were based on his history of
knowing how to run an effective kitchen
and at the same time
he had all kinds of his own like you
know neuroses and stuff that bled into
that and you see it in road runner
actually one of the parts i really liked
was when
he talks about
hey i'm not gonna stop for the cameras
you guys learn how to get fast
you get fast i do what i do yeah and
that was i loved because because like
because i could do it i was fast and i
loved working fast like that so yeah
super high standards with tony though
different than michael and james cameron
and i and i have not worked with james
cameron i know a number of people who
have though
i don't think you're ever going to get
that moment with
with michael or with someone like
michael mann or someone like james
cameron where you're like
sitting down and like drinking beers
with them out in the desert and talking
about like life and things that really
mean something and like with tony you
did and that was the difference he was
actually he was a friend and and a very
very important friend you know
who i miss every single day
he was not
those guys he wasn't an [ __ ] he could
be an [ __ ] you know he could be an
[ __ ] all the time he could be
incredibly frustrating to work with
but he but there was something under it
there was something very loving there
there was something very caring and once
you were kind of
in
his sphere he really he really did care
about people so from that perspective it
was different from the work perspective
though
he wasn't gonna mince words in the same
way that he wasn't gonna mince words
when a dish isn't right
in the kitchen like you can't it doesn't
work that way
unless you want 20 [ __ ] risottos sent
back
you better get the first one right and
when someone [ __ ] it up you better let
them know that they [ __ ] it up big
time right now immediately and correct
the problem
and that was a lot of the process with
tony in post for sure in the field it
was more like things that were
cumbersome or inconvenienced tony he
didn't like messiness he didn't like
sitting around and like you know that
when [ __ ] goes south on a crew i mean my
god we just look like a bunch of look
like a bunch of chickens with our heads
cut off running around trying to make
[ __ ] happen or trying to make [ __ ] work
and there's a lot of reasons that that
can happen you know he didn't like any
of that and you'd hear about unfucking
yourself quite a bit in those moments
but when it came to posts like
that's a much more calculated thing and
like i would send him rough cuts and
everyone has been through this
i would send him rough cuts where
he i mean from the very beginning he's
like
what
possible
reason do you have for presenting me
with
this piece of garbage i didn't work so
hard dot dot
in full caps you didn't work so hard
to have your work flush down the toilet
by this [ __ ] editor
you know
and you're like oh
okay
are we gonna like are we gonna go in a
constructive direction like what do you
you know
and
but he would and and and that's that was
the thing about him is that
the good ones are right you know
michael mann as much of an [ __ ] as he
was to people
you'd have to kind of be like well he's
right though you know that's right he
knows and he's right he's not wrong with
tony
also
90 of the time he was he was right
and
it wasn't up to it wasn't up to the
standards
what was cool about tony is that then he
would he would go on and work the
material
you would start
reforming it you'd start working with
him he'd give constructive
notes and that's something that i tell
people or try to like
explain to people and i think that
people should know about him and
something i do you know kind of wish
they had said in road runner two it's
like
he's
tony was a
you go on his wikipedia and it's like
celebrity chef and it's like yeah that's
not how i think of him no and he wasn't
that great of a chef
it's also just that label doesn't i i
didn't know him at all but the label
doesn't make any sense yeah it sounds so
hollow to me given the breadth of what
he did also right 100
to me what he was more than anything
else within my sphere of working with
him was he was a
absolutely
incredible television producer
and he understood story he understood
story's structure he understood
cinematography he understood using the
tools of film to make something that was
cinematic even though we were on you
know making our little show on tv it was
like it always wanted to be a feature
film and so we were using like
our limited resources to get as close to
that benchmark as possible
it should look beautiful the framing
should be great the lighting should be
great you know the music needs to be
great
the editing the pace the build up the
way that you present subjects you know
all of that stuff needs to be at the
highest level and that's what people are
seeing i think when they respond to the
show and the kind of response that the
show has gotten which is really
incredible they're seeing a couple
things authenticity because we never did
[ __ ] twice we never faked anything
that's all real everything you see is
real we didn't set up shots we didn't
call cut we didn't call action we got
fast
we did what he told us to do we got fast
you see authenticity and you see just a
very very high level of
production value
given
our resources and i think it's something
that
something that i
constantly want to point out to people
is like look at the weight classes that
we were punching in we were way out of
our group you know i got we're going out
on shows where we're shooting for seven
days in the field
we had we had a
three thousand dollar
external equipment rental budget
and we're getting cinematography
nominations my last cinematography
nomination was up against free solo it
was up against free solo
we're punching way out of our class and
that was because of the very high
standards then that can only come from
the top yeah
we were down with it because over the
time he was powerful enough and the the
show was magnetic enough to pull in
people who were very talented who were
gifted who
really wanted to do like good work and
push the genre as far as they could
but that comes from the top and that was
that was tony and that was that's what
you get from that impeccable nature of
like no everything needs to be good
and also you just tony was so [ __ ]
cool that
you really wanted to please him on my
wall i have framed
the best email i ever got from him
it was when i sent him the first act of
the nigeria show
and that we shot in lagos and it just
says out [ __ ] standing with two
exclamation points and then under it
says couldn't be happier
and i framed it and i put it on my wall
that is so cool
maybe that tells you a little bit i mean
that's like the highest moment of my
career so
you know there are two things
and there are many others but two things
that jump to mind as i'm listening to
you describe all this
you know the first is that
when you watch road runner
yeah
and i'd never seen any of this
archival footage
but
it took a while for
tony to find
the path to express himself
authentically in front of cameras right
it wasn't
immediate it wasn't automatic yeah it
took
some screwing around
and
throwing a lot against the wall to get
there and when i think of
some of my favorite episodes and i don't
know if you were
on this particular episode i'm going to
reference but there are many examples of
this
the
the authenticity of things going totally
sideways and him being really [ __ ]
pissed off and having the writing chops
to actually make it into a super
entertaining scene are you talking about
the sicily show i think it was sicily
with the octopus and the guy throwing
the octopus can you okay tell
that's funny you and i have never talked
about this but you knew exactly what i
was thinking about yeah it's the best
example of it so please tell this story
because it's so [ __ ] hilarious oh my
god well i wasn't there it was directed
by
sally freeman who's an incredible
director and one of my like favorite
[ __ ] people in the world
she is just this
ass kicking salty brit
who doesn't take any [ __ ] from anyone
she's the only person i've ever seen be
able to refer to tony as [ __ ] cakes to
his face without being summarily fired
which in and of itself is a tremendous
achievement
i literally saw her in finland in the
hotel lobbies say to the group wears
shitcakes
with tony standing right behind her and
then turned around and she says oh there
you are so
hats off to sally
she must have been good at what she did
yeah
she was directing that and i and i don't
think that that that wasn't premeditated
on her part i mean they were going to go
out they were going to die for octopus
but i think she as i recall
she said that like she kind of knew they
were [ __ ] when they got there because
it's like it was like a popular beach
there's like tons of people in the water
it's like this whole thing the guy shows
up
you know they go they're putting around
in the water looking for octopus or of
course there are no octopus there
because the water on that beach was
probably 20 urine
and all of a sudden so the way tony
described it and we talked to him we
were in tokyo with him like right after
this happened and he's telling us this
story now we were sitting in the bar
of the park hyatt in tokyo right where
bill murray
was in
in lost in translation
soaking up just being in that space and
being like this is the spot we're very
wise
and tony's saying like you wouldn't
believe it i was in sicily i'm
underwater all of a sudden this dead
[ __ ] octopus floats down to the
bottom of the ocean and i realize what's
happening is because the the other diver
goes and claims the octopus the the dead
limp octopus off the bottom of the ocean
and goes to the surface and holds it up
as if he's found the octopus so it's a
total setup
and i think it was actually a really
miserable moment for tony because he was
not when we got to tokyo he wasn't like
oh i'm gonna write this thing and it's
gonna be great and we're gonna figure it
out and it's gonna be funny he was like
that was the worst [ __ ] moment of my
life
he went into like a whole of existential
angst he as you know in the show he goes
and he downs like six negroni's after
that oh yeah he just [ __ ] off and walks
down the beach and just gets
beyond hammered yeah that's right
he was genuinely bummed and the reason
he was genuinely bummed is because he
felt like
it was a breach of
of exactly what we were talking about of
that authenticity you know and the thing
that
had really been the most important
trading capital of the show up until
that point was
yeah well not up until that point i mean
there are other examples of that and
that certainly didn't break that
but he but he was bummed about it
i think i think it's also a testament to
sally that she was able to say hey no
this is there's something here that's
like really funny and really worth
exploring
and then he wrote to it and it ends up
being this iconic scene
lots of people talk about it
but what you're seeing there is a real
response from tony he was
genuinely bummed out so let me come back
to the quote framed on your wall for a
second yeah and this is this is going to
be a bit of a non-sequitur from what we
were just talking about the plop plop
plop as i recall the voiceover was
something like
plop plop and then i realized what was
happening
he's poor dead octopus being thrown into
the water around him are there any
particular quotes poems books
memorabilia could be anything that you
have found to be
meaningful enough to revisit
more than once could be anything i'm
just thinking about this letter on your
this email on your wall did i keep
around my house
do you keep around your house or that
you keep inside your head it could be
anything it's full of stuff
[ __ ]
this is
the piece of paper that he was typing
we needed a scene of when we did the
tangiers episode we needed a scene of
him typing
right yep and so he's typing
and we're just filming him type and this
is what he wrote
it was the best of times it was the
worst of times call me ishmael this is
the saddest story ever told jackie brown
at 26 with no expression on his face
said he could get some guns you're
watching cnn you're watching mind of a
chef you're watching treme on hbo you're
watching the layover you're watching
repeats of no reservations so this is
him just
freestyle typing i don't know why i
picked it up it's on my wall
my life is full of these things i have
[ __ ] everywhere from just
stuff that i picked up when we were on
the road with tony
like an adobe brick from martha i have a
muzzle break from west virginia you know
i have a lighter that josh homey gave us
when we did the show with queens
you know
just
collected crap everywhere
i'll narrow it down so
let's assume
family any pets
photo albums all of that is in the clear
but house is burning down you can take
three to five
of these many items that you have
[ __ ] it let it burn
let it all burn okay there's all right
that's a fair answer
we're more in the spirit of tony i'm
probably grabbing the emmy
[Laughter]
i don't know man you know honestly all
jokes aside it all means something to me
like these are the things i decorate my
house with
these are the things i want around
this is the greatest thing i ever got to
do in my life was be with tony to travel
the world with tony to see
a
world that
a tiny handful of people get to see
because the price of admission
as a civilian as someone who just wanted
to go out and do those things would be
so extraordinarily high that you just
you can't achieve it it wasn't like
oh we you know we got to go on some
sweet vacations it wasn't like oh i have
the money to go to the maldives and stay
in like a sick
resort it wasn't like that we had access
we had things that no one else will ever
get because of who tony was
and that is why this [ __ ] is special to
me you cannot do this again this is not
replicable and
i think it's actually a lesson that the
tv industry needs to learn because i
hear a lot of it's the boarding of this
it's the bourdain of that it's the
bourdain of that and you're like no it's
not because the first word you're using
is bourdain and that is gone
and it's not coming back yeah we got to
stop trying you know this was a singular
experience and
i think i think we're all very aware of
that so yeah i decorate my house with
the detritus of
traveling the world with tony and i'm
[ __ ] proud of it
junk all over my house
so tony
and we don't have to we don't have to
explore this it's going to segue to a
question about you tony obviously had
things in his sort of psychological
psycho-emotional bag
as i think you mentioned earlier you do
yeah
and
we all have our our demons
of different types you know
battles we're fighting that no one knows
about or maybe only a few people know
about
for the
anxiety and
bipolar
disorder and so on
what have you found
to be
most effective in terms of tools or
behaviors or anything at all for helping
with those things for you
so work in progress you know
bipolar i mean you can
i i'm not i'm i'm still trying to go
unmedicated i don't want to go on a on a
mood stabilizer they're pretty pretty
heavy
consistency
is
is really important it's a hard thing to
do when you're traveling the world is is
have a consistent schedule
but having a consistent schedule i
have no proof of this
this is probably this probably gets into
your world and your expertise a lot more
than mine but i find
techno i listen to a lot of techno
really a bluetooth headset and i will
listen to seven eight hours of techno
straight while i work
and it's like a metronome for my head it
keeps me planted on task
clean
yeah so those things exercise
eating right all of those those are the
ways that i'm trying to deal with with
my bag but yeah we all have them tony
definitely had plenty of them but i also
think that
most of the people on our crew did you
know we kind of like were a
a collection of like minds and i don't
want to speak for anyone but i think
what we found in the end when we kind of
looked around the room and these are the
people and my life that i like
i hold was like the highest regard and
like the greatest value that
we were all people who had
strong creative capacity and
were all
for one reason or another kind of
i don't want to say the island of misfit
toys because it's so corny but it it you
know it's got kind of an element of that
you know everyone was kind of had like a
thing that was broken
and in a thing that they were struggling
with and you kind of knew those things
but the but those that brokenness in in
the kind of pain that comes out of that
i think was critical
in terms of looking at the world through
the lens that we were trying to look at
the world through
where we were trying to see everything
we were trying to see the beauty we were
trying to see the pain we were trying to
see all of it that's not a formulaic
show that's not a show that like
everything's gonna end happy every time
it's not a show where you're gonna hit
happy beats every time it's not like an
upbeat travel show or like oh today
we're you know
it's it's not it was it was a it was an
exploration of the world in in all of
the permutations of what that means
and if you don't understand pain
you don't understand fear
you don't
know those things you are never going to
be able to see it you're not going to be
able to see it and and i don't mean to
be
dismissive of anyone but
i remember we you know at one point we
had a new editor coming on for a show
and i talked to him for 10 minutes on
the phone
and i asked him a few questions what's
your favorite shows what's your life
like what are your hobbies and stuff
like that and i called our showrunner
sandy's wig and i said i'm sorry
i i this isn't going to work
and she's like why and i was like he's
too [ __ ] happy his life's too good
is everything's okay with him
and and he's not going to get it
and he didn't
and
that wasn't prophetic on my part it was
just knowing that we had to embrace
those things and so
you know you get to the end and
what happened
happened all those things there's a lot
of different ways to analyze that but
what's i think important to note is that
those
those things
those that experience of
pain and and
and dealing with those things was a
critical part of making the show
and it came with a lot of [ __ ] that we
were kind of all hot to trot on at the
time but i did i look back and i'm like
you know a lot of alcohol tim like
there was a lot of like
you know and i'll speak only for myself
there's a lot of
i mean almost daily i mean yes daily
just drink yourself to sleep wake up in
the morning hammer [ __ ] coffee
go on adrenaline and caffeine as far as
you can and then start drinking again
and come down and that was
that was the rhythm of the gear shifts
every day
and that's kind of how we got through it
why did you stop drinking when
when tony died is it because you felt
that was maybe a contributing factor was
it for other reasons and i'm not asking
you to speculate i'd just love to hear
hear your thinking you know what your
experience was i want to be careful
about not speculating i want to be
respectful to everyone in tony's sphere
i will say this it is impossible for me
to separate alcohol
from tony's death and
and that's kind of a reality for me is
like
and i and i and i feel like
you know other people on the show felt
that way as well again i don't want to
speak for them there's a lot of people
involved in this there's a lot of people
that have their own journeys there are
people who are a lot closer with tony
than i was
but i was fairly close with him
and
after he died i could not separate
alcohol
from
from his death
i don't mean in a i don't mean
that he died because he had been
drinking i just mean that that was part
of the calculus
uh for sure it was in there and it's a
dangerous drug and it's severely
underestimated
in our culture you know
and uh and i just couldn't do it anymore
i like couldn't
and i went hard for a long time
what did that process look like for you
uh removing that
stop drinking
was it easy i mean was it
hard to not it was frantic
tell me more yeah
i stopped drinking i got a mountain bike
and like i i swear for the first couple
months
i was riding i was riding every night i
was riding
20 miles a night up on the fire roads
outside of my house and this is in the
months after
tony
died
and i would ride from my house up to the
nike station
on dirt mall holland and back in this
it's you know 10 miles each way
it's not the hardest 10 miles i'm not
like you know i don't think i'm lance
armstrong i'm definitely not lance
armstrong
but that's where i was and i was alone
at night riding
and just trying to i don't know trying
to make sense of [ __ ]
it was dark right after the month after
he died i went pretty hard
i woke up on my lawn one night
you mean went hard drinking yeah like i
drank like a bottle of tequila i woke up
on my lawn scared myself i have two
young kids
and i was like this is this this must
end good for you man yeah a lot of
people do it
yeah and and they all need credit
it's it's it's a hard thing
to uh to do
yeah let me ask you a related question
as i as i watched road runner
which is yeah it's a i thought it was
well done i'm sure it's imperfect but
there were
some takeaways that seemed
to
take aways or perspectives that seemed
to be shared by more than one person and
one of them was
that when tony was doing jiu jitsu
seriously he was in one or perhaps in
one of the better places like psycho
emotionally speaking yeah definitely
parallel with that
i'm thinking about something you said
earlier in this conversation that i i
just want to highlight because i'm not
sure people understand just what it
requires and that is
running through the wilderness with a 50
pound backpack
with a camera on your shoulder being
able to use one hand and maybe the
technology has changed but when you and
i were
spending time together
and i was able to watch you film this is
not an iphone that you're using to film
and this is this this is a significant
rig on
i don't know how much it weighs i mean
what what would you say at the time i
don't know 20 20 plus pounds for sure i
would imagine yeah probably 20 plus
pounds we were on slightly bigger
cameras
for tim ferriss experiment though than
what we use like with meat eater
mediator with slightly smaller cameras
but it doesn't really matter it's
incredibly physical yeah it's very
physical there were days we were doing
15 miles of back country
that
that may not sound like a lot that's
that's a fair amount when you're doing
it day to day when you're in snow when
you're in environments that that you're
not on a trail you're in back country
you know there's a lot of again i'm not
trying to pretend like i'm super rugged
but
it definitely took some doing
you're pretty rugged man i mean i don't
want to you know overstate it but you're
pretty rugged and
where i was going with that is you know
you've been very physical
which i would uh you know i'm
speculating but i would imagine that's
been
good medicine for you to be that active
100
yeah what are your versions of jiu-jitsu
like the activities that seem to nourish
you
and
counter balance maybe some of these
things that you're carrying in your bag
right the anxiety the bipolar etc when
would people say you are at your best
what type of activities
what are my hobbies
yeah sure
surfing
mountain biking
and i was really into racquetball for a
long time but i my knees are kind of
my knee has been a little tough on me
with racquetball
you know those things for me when you're
doing them you're not doing anything
else you know surfing's got a solitary
element to it that's almost like
meditation doesn't even matter if you're
really catching waves i mean that's like
a bonus but you're sitting there you
have the rhythm of the ocean you're
thinking
you're processing things but
you're on liquid you know and you're
staring out at the ocean waiting for
waves
it's
it's unbelievable i mean it's very very
centering and there's a reason that
there are stereotypes of of surfers you
know it's true you get a surfer home to
you
i like mountain biking because it's it's
really physical it's a it's like a real
grind it really pushes your heart rate
but when also when you're doing like you
know like i said i like to kind of
enduro style stuff
you got a lot of [ __ ] coming at you fast
and you're making a lot of calculations
a lot of decisions you know i i like
that it's very dynamic and i tend to
like solitary kind of sports
racquetball's just
fast and
and it's and it's if for anyone who
knows racquetball it's it's a killer
game
you know you're looking for kill shots
you're
you're playing strategy you're playing
geometry
and looking for opportunities to
to execute kill shots and it's a blast
i don't know i like aggressive [ __ ] and
i like [ __ ] that like keeps your heart
rate way up
all right i'm gonna use the door that
was just opened by the use of the word
geometry and then we're going to
go to muzzle break in west virginia
because
we made a promise earlier to come back
to west virginia yeah but i i mentioned
the dance i remember watching and this
is segwanged into the geometry and you
really need
kind of two players in the game maybe to
to fully visualize this at least yeah at
least which is why
i wanted to mention
marcus lehmann
who was also working on tim ferriss
experiment great guy very skilled
and watching the two of you guys
dance with geometry was
so fun to the extent that it was almost
not distracting but i was so intrigued
and
almost just puzzled by how you guys
could pull it off so for someone who has
no idea what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
could you
just explain how geometry plays into
what we were doing or what you would do
with steve and so on
so if you picture it in a basic sense
right say you have two characters who
are talking to each other they're
standing in a room and they're facing
each other this is like very simple you
know kind of this is a very simple setup
right
we are not a scripted show there is no
script right
we need to capture as much of that
conversation for the edit as possible in
real time when you're on a scripted show
you can shoot one camera on one angle of
that conversation and then you can move
the camera to the other angle of that
conversation and shoot the other side
right so you're shooting one character
first and you move and you shoot the
other character when we're doing
documentary stuff you can't do that you
need to get it in the moment so we have
at least two cameras right and so one
camera is shooting one angle on
you know character a
and one camera shooting the other angle
on character b right
now
that's the basic setup and you could
just stand there and you could be in one
frame size and whatever and you could
cover the conversation and the editor
will cut back and forth between those
two cameras as they see fit but it's
going to be boring like you you want to
add dynamics so you're going to need to
add movement to that scenario you're
going to need to move your characters
around the room you're gonna need to
allow them to go on some kind of
endeavor you know you're gonna need to
they need to accomplish some goal they
need to do whatever so they start moving
and now the geometry is always changing
right
now you need to be shooting both sides
of that interaction you also need to be
shooting your insert shots you need to
be shooting wider shots to give you a
context of the environment you need to
be shooting all of the supporting
footage that tells you where you are and
what those characters are doing and you
need to have that in your head and you
can't talk out loud i can't like i i
mean i can talk on milwaukee you know a
little bit to the other camera operator
but when you're really doing it well you
know and i guess again there's a million
different ways to do this there's all
kinds of different
ways that people achieve this but when
you're doing it really well with someone
who really knows what they're doing
you know and inherently i know because
of the action because of where the other
camera is standing
i know what their shot is i know where
their lens is i know where
their background is i know where not to
cross into their shot i know what they
have
so you're simultaneously watching them
and understanding what they're covering
and where they are
and you're reacting to that or you're
establishing
your shot and they're reacting to you
right when it's really good it moves
that way without conversation and after
you shoot with someone for a while you
really get into a rhythm where you both
know what the other person has you know
what the other person's shooting and as
your characters move around the world as
they do their you know thing
you know
how to move together to maintain that
coverage
there's a variable in that which
dictates a lot of this which is called
the 180 degree rule right
so picture this
there's a car
moving along a bridge right
and you are shooting from a helicopter
out
on the passenger side of the car
tracking along with it right you can
picture that got it again the direction
of the car then if you're doing that is
moving from frame right to frame left
right that is the way that the action
moves
if you then cut to a shot from the
driver's side tracking a lot oh wait a
second let me could you say that one
more time so i'm imagining in my head
right i'm in the helicopter passenger
side it's so much easier when you can
draw it out passenger side is on the
right hand side of the car
passenger side is on the right hand side
of the car right right and you're moving
along with them and the car is going
along and so when you see that shot on
the screen the car is moving in a
direction that is
from the left hand side of the screen
left side left side i messed it up left
hand side of the screen to the right
hand side of the screen right the car is
pointed to the right now if you
go and you switch over and you shoot
from the driver's side
what direction is the car going when it
goes on screen it's going the opposite
it's going right to left you've crossed
the 180 degree line
i don't believe like you know a lot of
these rules are just set up to be broken
right so there's a lot of variables in
there but in a basic sense you are
confusing your audience because the car
that was going left to right is now
going right to left and that is
confusing when you're following the
continuity of an edit the same thing
with a conversation if you are if you
have two characters and the cameras are
standing
on the same side of those characters you
have one character which is looking
screen direction left right and then you
have one character that's looking screen
direction right and you're cutting in
between those now if one of those
characters if one of those cameras
crosses that line
you now have two characters either
looking screen direction right or screen
direct and left and when you try to cut
between them it won't make sense because
they both look like they're looking away
from each other right yeah it's like
when it's done well you don't notice it
but when it's screwed up you really
notice and that's right i was watching a
super high budget scripted show
i'm not going to mention the name and
they messed this up it was like a bunch
of royalty seated at a long table on one
side having a conversation and it was so
confusing
to my brain that it was uncomfortable i
think what people don't appreciate a lot
is that you need to establish the
geometry of your environment in order
for for people to understand what's
going on in a physical sense when you're
in a scene right
there's a lot of tricks to doing that
and there are some things that you can
do that
break that and that's one of the things
that you can do that breaks that so but
now picture you have two characters who
are now like i keep thinking of
the
the one we did in vegas right yeah what
did we call that episode it wasn't uh
the gambling one it was we did two in
vegas we did uh we did the poker the
heads up poker no we did the evasive
driving invasive yes or evasive
tactics right because it was also on
foot it was getting out of zip ties and
yeah exactly so you have two characters
moving around in a dynamic environment
there and they're constantly crossing
each other they're constantly crossing
the line they're constantly moving
around now you need to know where that
180 degree line is all the time and both
your cameras need to be tuned up enough
to move with that line and reestablish
that line without thinking about it and
without talking and that's the dance
that you're seeing so when you talk
about the dance the dance is really
maintaining that coverage in a way that
is going to make sense for the editor
and ultimately make sense for the
audience
and it is difficult to learn
and once you do learn it like with
anything else that's
fun to do
it's a blast yeah it's really cool to
work with someone that understands how
that works
i don't know if this is the schedule we
had was was normal if it is i don't know
how the hell you guys do it for so long
pretty normal yeah i remember we had
whatever was like 13 weeks of shooting
and it was like five or six days of
shooting a half day to a day of
transition to another location if
necessary and then you're right back
into shooting yeah and then uh then i
was reviewing rough cuts and so on at
night
which was just a really
incredible introduction to the velocity
of that type of production yeah but but
what i was going to say is it also makes
it sometimes hard to remember because
they were moving pieces and sometimes
people wouldn't be available for a week
or two were you on the new york city
episode with josh waitskin and maurice
ashley yeah that was amazing yeah so i
want to mention one scene because it's
it's a it's a super fun scene but it
also demonstrates
how
well
shooters
can dance this dance in a complex
environment you probably know where i'm
going but this is grand master maurice
ashley playing this hustler
the trash talker i loved it oh my god
some favorite things i've ever seen it's
incredible and people can find this clip
actually on the youtube channel for
grandmaster maurice ashley and i i want
to see how many views it has now it's
got yeah nine million views this is just
such an incredible scene in washington
square park yeah it was amazing so maybe
you could just walk us through since
this is a real world example right
if you recall just
what were some of the considerations
what was happening because we're sitting
in washington square park it's freezing
out
like if people are wearing their winter
clothing and this is where
while a you know josh waitskin who was
the basis for searching for bobby
fischer about the book in the movie yeah
played as a little kid it's where
in the details from maurice ashley it's
where the the late great vinnie
livermore used to beat my ass at the
same table this is from him
uh maybe you could just if you remember
any of the experience just kind of walk
through because this is
complex this is it seems to me at least
like hard to get right and it just
came out so so well
so i don't remember the specifics of the
blocking i remember it was one of the
coolest things that i've ever seen
because you had this grand master chess
player sit down with a new york city
street hustler and listen though i mean
i don't know [ __ ] about chess but i know
that those new york city street hustlers
are damn good chess players and they
play fast yeah they can play and we
watched a grand master sit down and
devour this cat as if he just didn't
even exist and also return fire with
[ __ ] talking in equal measure right
that's right ann called him out when he
tried to when he tried to knock the
pieces over and hustle him yeah it
reminded me there was a famous quote i
forget the name of the crow scout who
was working with the u.s cavalry when
custer
was decimated at little bighorn but they
asked him after how long it took and he
said about as long as it takes a hungry
man to eat a sandwich
and that's how we described custer
getting taken down a little bighorn and
that's how it would describe that grand
master running through that cat he
[ __ ] devoured him it was so
satisfying to watch not because i have
anything against the street hustler by
the way but just to see someone that
proficient at something was incredible
oh it's great yeah i don't remember the
specific blocking but this is what i
would say in remembering that scene and
and thinking about how i would go into
that right so you know a couple things
going in you know that it's going to be
all about their the energy between them
right and so you're looking at tight
shots of eyes you're looking at like
establishing their their connection and
establishing the board you have two
things going on the connection between
them right in the [ __ ] talking and all
that stuff and then what's going on in
the board and you gotta cover what's
going on on the board too and then you
have the crowd around them i'm getting
to that part right i'm getting that part
because
you in their dynamic you need to cover
the game right you need to cover the
game but you need to be quick enough to
know that you got to get up to the two
shot you also got to establish the
environment right and part of the
environment and part of what you know is
going to tell the story is the reaction
of the people that are standing around
so you got to get out to those wide
shots got to see where the crowd is got
to see where where you know kind of
everyone is placed right got to get in
on the details of the game got to get in
on their rapport and then you got to
start
searching the audience that crowd that
was standing there for the telling
reaction shots and so what i'm standing
in an environment like that i'll be
doing my coverage looking around and any
moment i get i'm looking up and i'm like
who's the most expressive here who's the
person that's gonna come out with the
big line who's the person that's gonna
and i think i remember that day someone
being like eventually to the street
hustler guy like
like kind of patting him on the shoulder
and being like do you know do you know
who this is
if i write about that i feel like he
like at one point someone was like yeah
there was there was definitely a moment
yeah there was absolutely exactly and so
it's it's looking it's looking for that
and understanding in two cameras you
know you know that the people that are
on your side of the line the other
camera is going to have them people that
are on
the other side of the line you have them
and you're kind of those that's how you
divvy up their responsibility
but if you miss it you miss it and
remember these are not actors you cannot
go back you cannot get those original
reactions again no way you have to get
it in the moment and that's where it
gets back to tony and when he said you
be fast and he was he was right about
that
and it pissed a lot of people off a lot
of people come on to the show and be
like this is [ __ ] we don't like get
time to set up we don't get something to
do that and i'd be like dude you are not
cut out for this show or
not just dude
a lot of women
in our line of work too but
you are you're not gonna make it here
because what you don't understand is
that you're [ __ ] it up by trying to
get it right yeah you gotta learn how to
not miss it the first time and and it
might not be perfect it might not be
pretty but you gotta get it
and that's so that's how i would
that's how i would think about a scene
like that
the most important element being that it
doesn't happen again happens once
yeah 100 percent and what made that
scene also
so gratifying is that maurice
is
like a handsome charismatic yes
morpheus
in a black leather jacket morpheus and
can also just murder people on the
chessboard and trash talk really well so
it's so fun we'll put it we'll put a
link in the in the show notes yeah
that's worth watching
so what i'm pulling up you may never
guess who i texted so i texted uh john
bedolis and chris vivian yeah
and so john directed a ton of these uh
tim ferriss experiment episodes and so i
asked him what topics and questions he
thought might be fun to explore
okay this is gonna be interesting he has
some good ones and i'll i'll start with
and there are many different ways we
could go here but like from dp to
director showrunner what skills or
habits do you find help most in
transitioning
from a more narrowly creative role to a
broader creative role with more
managerial responsibilities yeah so
there are many ways to approach this i
mean i suppose the the simplest way
would just be to say
what advice would you give to someone
who is really technical and good
at one thing right they deliver they're
really exceptional
and they hope to
embrace or they're being asked to
embrace a role that is broader with
managerial responsibilities like what
would you what advice would you give to
your younger self as you were doing that
or to someone else who's in a similar
position
get ready to relinquish control because
if you don't you're gonna smother the
people who are working under you you
need to trust them
and you need to be able to work with the
people who need work
in a proactive manner to get them to the
place where you need them to be because
you are not going to be able to control
everything anymore when you have the
camera in your hand you have this tiny
little world in the viewfinder and you
can control every aspect of it as you
start to climb the ladder
up to directing and then to show running
you need to depend on other people so
part of that is bringing good people in
the other part is understanding
when you need
to let people do their job well let's
get super specific so this i would
imagine is super hard for people who are
very
proficient in
something they are now supervising right
like you were talking about that with
the dps right and you're just like you
sure that's my shot like why don't you
move over a little bit yeah i think
maybe
maybe a little tighter
so does it mean
just picking your battles well and like
letting things go that you can let go
but holding a really strong line on
certain quality decisions where you need
to push a little bit i i just love to
hear because it doesn't sound easy to
just like flip a switch
i don't think it is easy and i think it
took me some time and i had times when i
blew up at camera operators or dps that
i really
regret because it was like exactly the
wrong way to go about things you know
and i had i had a dp who i really really
respect we had a pretty vicious exchange
in the field
one time and he came to me after and
he's like dude he's like you took what
was just a lovely
delightful day where we were getting
great stuff and you [ __ ] murdered it
over a detail
and and you've ruined the whole vibe of
of the day in the shoot and that was
really profound for me and i thought
about that a lot
for what because like he missed a shot
like i knew was there i know i was right
i know the shot was there i knew the
shot would make the edit i knew it was
important
why i had to rip his head off about it i
have no idea now i don't do that anymore
so i think that one aspect is just
finding ways to approach
what you need to get in a way that's
positive and proactive we worked with
angelo dundee when we were doing ali
angela dundee's i mean to just fill
everyone in who doesn't know angelo
dundee was ali's trainer he's one of the
great boxing trainers of all time so you
want to talk about a level of
expectation and perfection i mean that
is operating at the very highest level
of that but he wouldn't come in and be
like
hey dude
your jab sucks and like what the [ __ ]
why am i wasting my time and blah blah
blah all this stuff
he would come to ali and he'd be like
hey you know i was watching your jab
you're doing really good with that jab i
love the way that you're doing
this even if it was something that ali
wasn't doing he was trying to point out
something to to get a to get a response
to get him to focus on a particular
aspect of that movement you know
and i think that that's really important
and in finding ways to work with people
and say
get what you want in a way that is
a little smarter than just coming out
and just hammering folks so what might
you have said
to that guy the the newer version of you
how might you have handled that
situation
in retrospect now
i think the number one thing is i i like
i would stay calm
didn't stay calm in that moment because
i was kind of dying because i knew i
needed shot but i think i would stay
calm and say hey listen like this is
happening right now you need to break
off let go what you're doing don't worry
about the shot that you're on we're fine
on that i got it in post but we need
this right now
i think that's a pretty easy explanation
you know yeah but we tend not to do that
because we're
so controlling that in the moment it
feels like you know it feels like you're
losing control and that's not the truth
i think that as you
as you get older you get more experience
with management
unless you're going to be a jim cameron
or a michael mann unless you're going to
be a tyrant which trust me that's 20
hours a day of work hard work yeah i'm
not i'm not that and i'm not going to do
it and i never was
and i don't want to treat people like
that
and and listen no shade on them what
they do is unbelievable
but
i think i know myself enough now to know
that that's not how the style
and how i'm going to accomplish what i
need to accomplish i think it's building
people up now
and saying like i trust you think about
it this way
think about it this way try this you
know i know from experience i can tell
you
that this this is gonna work but i don't
know being willing to work with people
so let's come back to that muzzle break
on your shelf
right maybe you can explain what a
muzzle break is to people and then
let's talk about
the the return to west virginia
and why it matters a muzzle break first
of all it's a way to dispense the energy
of the bullet coming out
of
of the gun it it can provide accuracy
and and safety by
basically pushing the energy of
firing the bullet out to the sides right
this muzzle break was made by jmac
customs and west virginia which is cool
because they're a they're an independent
operation
which
takes people who you know were laid off
in coal mines and various other
extractive industries that have left
west virginia and put some to work and
trains them as machinists
and they do high quality work i'm not
particularly into guns
but i respect what they're doing and
probably get a little bit of
commentary online about my understanding
of the dynamics of muzzle brakes but
that's what i know that's what the
internet's for yeah
west virginia for me you know and this
is a very personal story so if everyone
can bear with me like west virginia for
me was the most important thing that i
ever did and when i say west virginia
i'm like talking about the the parts
unknown
episode of west virginia i had lived in
west virginia when i was a kid
and
my family went through a pretty tough
time when we were
there parents were you know kind of on
the rocks
west virginia can be a tough place
especially in that time you know it's a
place that's been hit really hard by by
the dynamics of of extractive industries
and capitalism and
listen i'm not bitching about capitalism
like i believe in i believe in
capitalism maybe not our particular form
of it but
for the most part i believe in it
but
you have a state that was really
predicated on the coal industry and as
soon as they found easier cheaper coal
in china and in wyoming they
just dropped those people like they
didn't even exist and so it created a
tough environment and i grew up
to some degree in west virginia in in an
environment that was kind of tough we
didn't have running water electricity
etc there's also some things i remember
about it they're very fond but it was
like a
really formative moment in my life and
i had really bad associations with west
virginia for a long time
and wouldn't you know just wouldn't
think about it wouldn't go there i went
back in 2003 after i stopped working for
michael mann and i happened to be there
in southern west virginia and when there
was really bad flooding and i saw these
people and
had this moment where i was just like
these like you're talking about like the
heart and soul of america
especially when you get down to southern
west virginia that is a
mixed group of
white folks black folks
who came
to that area to build lives for
themselves and in the process built this
country
and we basically [ __ ] on them
we
engage in these ridiculous hyperbolic
stereotypes of who they are
we consider them
to be
uneducated and and i mean how many jokes
do you know about
hillbillies
it's not true
these are like the hardest working most
independent
rugged self-determining people and
that's the reason they went to those
mountains in the first place
they are
the heart of who we're supposed to be as
a country you know
and i think we've seen and i don't want
to dive into politics here but i think
we've seen the result of what happens
when you [ __ ] on those people and you
ignore them they get [ __ ] angry and
they got a right to you know i always
wanted to go back and make a show from
what i saw there
and the hardships that those folks were
going through
and so
we were in antarctica with tony and i
pitched him on a west virginia show
and he was stoked on doing it and so i
got to go you know we got to go back to
the town of welsh in mcdowell county
mcdowell county is
the county it's the
highest percentage population loss in
the united states for any county
over the past 50 years
the place has just been like decimated
it's always number two or three on the
most impoverished counties list in the
united states
and we went there and i had this moment
where i was like
you know like taking tony to a place
where there's no restaurants there's no
food you know it's like literally a food
desert
is he gonna like is he gonna connect
with this place is he gonna see
what i feel like i saw which was what i
feel like we were kind of always looking
for to some degree in the show which was
like the beauty that's underneath that
surface level you know
and we went there we we go through the
first couple days of shooting and then
tony starts tweeting like these tweets
like nothing you know moves me like this
place it's just all these like really
beautiful wonderful and like and i had
this moment where i was like yeah dude
it's tony man of course he gets it of
course like he gets what what you're
trying to show him of course he gets
these people in this place
and i think it was so important because
it showed you know on a show called
parts unknown we're going to like
central appalachia and the united states
i think it showed his ability to walk
into a context and environment this is
right after trump was elected by the way
you know to walk into a context and
environment and see people for who they
really are
not
who what our perception of them is not
based on his political feelings not
based on
anything but the just the evidence of
sitting down with someone and saying
like what what are your values what does
life mean to you what do you want what
are you looking for and as soon as he
saw who they were he he responded to it
we made this beautiful show it was one
of the few shows that we got to do where
cnn gave us extra time they gave us an
extended episode
the show won an emmy and i sent the emmy
back to welsh and it's in welsh it's
someone's house well now oh that's
amazing how cool and it was just for me
personally for me professionally
in every way it was like this is this is
full circle this is how you make peace
with something that's painful
in your childhood
you go and you confront it and you you
find out what's really there beneath the
surface and then you try to be
benevolent about
what it is and i guess that's in part
like now i'm kind of making a this a
little bit of a leap but
you know looking for like we said
earlier looking for the gift in
something you know
like here's this thing that was really
painful for me as a child but there was
this tremendous gift in it which was
like an understanding of this place
and a connection to it that allowed us
to go and do something
within our own country looking at
ourselves
at a time when we critically need it
because we are
[ __ ] falling apart if you haven't
noticed
you know yeah
yeah
anyone who hasn't noticed man
this might be time to take and take
another look at things but we need to we
need to connect with each other we need
to talk to each other you know we need
to be good to each other how are you
choosing the projects that you work on
now and how did you end up becoming
involved with
united shades of america
again this is like one of those lucky
moments where you're like oh well
obviously i'm gonna do that you know
we had taken
kamau bell
to
kenya on parts unknown
and
he you know we wanted to do that cnn
wanted to do a crossover show
kamau has a kenyan name though
and i don't know what his genetic
descent is but probably
west african not east african for those
who don't know who is kamel
kamau is a
comedian from oakland black comedian
from oakland who has
you know really i think carved out like
a niche for himself
dealing in
identity and
cultural issues
in the united states but from a comedic
lens you know and and has been someone
who's like really been willing to sit
down
with the other and have honest
conversations with them but do it in a
way that is
not so heavily laid
he's really kind of brilliant at that
again i mean one of these people that
i'm so lucky to have the opportunity to
work with because he's he's super smart
super dynamic
and is doing something at a time in
america where i like really believe
we need it where we are talking about
these things head on his current project
which i had absolutely nothing to do
with is
the four-part documentary on showtime on
bill cosby and i think it's really brave
a kamau to come out and like be willing
to have that conversation a lot of
people weren't so that's kind of that's
that's who he is we took him to kenya uh
simply because his name is kenyon
like
kamau in kenya
is like
dan here
it's just like you look at the phone
book and it's like half the people in
the phone book or come out
you know we went we shot this awesome
show there so cool went on safari we're
like
three feet from lions you know and
safari was black rhinos white rhinos
hung out with the masai hung out in
nairobi which is an incredible
incredible city again with like a really
young really vibrant really hard
working population that like is another
place that is just driving
this kind of like
i don't you know what how do you how
does one even say it i mean africa's on
fire right now and i i believe it's the
next real growth place i mean with some
hot centers around like lagos and
nairobi and accra and
other places but
shot this great show and at the end of
it
i kind of with a little bit of
scumbaggery producerness
said hey listen like if you're ever
dissatisfied with your production
company or if you ever just want to make
a change i shouldn't say dissatisfied
because i don't want to put words in his
mouth we'd love to work with you and we
got a call a year later and he wanted to
i guess
try something new so
we've been lucky enough to do that and
like it just i feel again i feel very
very lucky in that because at a time
when again we're like we're bleeding man
this this like great incredible country
that we have
we're hurting
you know and we gotta be we gotta be
able to talk about these things with
each other without ripping each other's
heads off more and more it feels like
we're just ripping each other's heads
off so
whereas my life was really focused on
like the external world you know the
world outside of the united states for
so many years with tony i felt like at a
time when
we really needed to look
inward i got a chance to you know i have
gotten a chance to do that with kamau
and it's been amazing
learned a tremendous amount about who we
are and i've seen some [ __ ] that i can't
unsee
i feel like it's so hard for us as white
americans to get a glimpse into
what it's like
to be black in this country
and i will never know that and i know
that i will never know that but i've
been able to see
with much clearer resolution than i
think a lot of people get to see
what that experience is like and i can't
i can't unsee it now
you know so
for whatever that's worth
like anyone in black america gives a
[ __ ] what i have to say about anything
but
well i mean be that as it may as you
mentioned
these are hard conversations to have but
if the conversations aren't had we're
[ __ ] i mean what are we gonna do
yeah i mean then what what's plan b in
that case we know what plan b is like
all you got to do is read history you
know what plan b is you know plan b is
blood man plan b is not good
yeah so better to go with plan a and
i was struck i didn't know about this
but when you mentioned that kamau was
working on this you said mini series for
showtime or like a four-part series
docu-series
on bill cosby yeah just premiered and i
don't know the content i don't know the
angle
i don't know him
not referring to bill but referring to
kamel yeah but that is a
ballsy move very you know that's that
that's a bold move and it's
i applaud that
however people may feel about bill cosby
like it's
to make a character study and a
historical study of that i think
is it seems important right it seems
important we have to talk about it we
want to fix these issues you have to
talk about it you know but
again for kamau and i don't want to
speak out of turn here
but
as a as a black comedian i look at what
bill cosby did and bill cosby broke more
goddamn barriers you know
what he accomplished was amazing and i
and that's why i think that
what ended up coming out about bill
cosby
which is pretty irrefutable you know
despite the fact that he is now
walking the streets
free that is soul crushing that is hard
to face that is hard to deal with when
you've looked at this as a person who
has been able to transcend
a lot of the boundaries that have have
held you down so i think as a as a black
american to do that and to take that on
head on is is
damn gutsy i i think you should be
applauded for that regardless again of
of how you feel
about cosby and and the cases
surrounding cosby in particular
what's next for you what are you most
hoping to do or looking forward to doing
in the next few years
i don't know man just wait waiting for
crickets to walk by
[Laughter]
waiting for crickets you seem to have
an uncanny ability to wait in the right
spots and to pick the right crickets i
must say
you're an excellent spider you're a
fantastic fantastic spider
i don't honestly know tim i mean like
you know you want to keep you want to
keep progressing right you want to keep
building and and keep
you know you want to see how far you can
go
i i think that
i'm open and i'm like open i want new
challenges just like everyone else you
know
and we'll see where that goes
i have another
bedola's question yeah and i'm gonna
read it exactly as he texted it to me
because i love
the brevity it's almost like a haiku
yeah so i would probably reword this
just because i'm a different person but
i i love it in its current form so i'm
going to
read it here we go you work with your
wife period potentially loaded situation
period how do you deal question mark so
this is this is this is though i think a
question that applies to a lot of people
how have you
navigated or made rules around or
figured out how to
coexist and collaborate
with a spouse
honestly
be willing to lose and be honest about
like
what is right in a particular situation
i think that we spend so much time
i think a lot of times in relationships
we've spent so much time trying to prove
that like
we're in control and competent i think
again it is giving someone the respect
to give them space and allow them to
take control of a situation you know i
mean we do that at home with the kids
we do that
in our household we do it at work you
know
and
i don't know i came up with this concept
but i didn't come up with it what the
[ __ ] am i talking about
i tapped into an age-old concept that i
feel like has some wisdom to it which is
this idea of strategic loss you know
yeah like be willing to lose some
[ __ ] battles
what are you trying to prove it's your
wife she's not i mean she's not going
anywhere
you know i hope
i needed to do a couple of things to
make it all work and this is the this is
the life i want you know
i want to work with my wife i want to
travel around the world with my wife i
want to like
be as much a part of helping her build
her career as i want to build my own
but it took
for me like coming to the point where i
had to be like you're gonna have to
learn how to
how to
lose not be right about everything give
her space let her learn
let her teach you
and follow through on the [ __ ] that you
say you're gonna do
and that to me is like number one
relationship killer right if we're just
talking about the relationships it's
like
you say you're gonna do something like
do it
yeah
don't not do it you're breaking trust
you know and when it came down to my
wife going back to work after
she raised the kids and you know went
through two home births without
medication i have to mention that
because she's rugged as [ __ ]
match made in heaven for mo fallon yeah
that's right
i i i said to her like if you go back to
work i will learn how to do this stuff i
promise you i will follow through on my
end of holding up the family my end of
the household duties learn how to do
this stuff you mean handling handling
the kids and so on
yeah it's hard that was perfect timing
yeah there's a big cute kid audio
this year
i think that that's gonna be okay um
um in the house there's a daddy long leg
in the house not on the paintings
i'll come handle it sweetheart i just
got to finish this up though so give me
10 minutes okay
maybe 10 or 15 minutes do we have to
worry about that
i need i do need some
[Applause]
oh man you can come play with it after
sweetie i love you i'll be in a sec i'm
so glad i slipped her that 20 to make
that appearance and talk about spiders
it was perfect
i mean for me it was like
realizing that you know anyone who
doesn't think that
taking care of kids in the household
isn't like a full-time professional job
is like it just has not done the work
and does not understand what goes into
it
yeah
it is a full-time gig and like if my
wife was going to go back to work and we
were going to have this future where we
could work together like i had to i had
to be willing to annie up i did and it
made all the difference
but
what a dream right you know i mean
just to put this in perspective a little
and i uh sure i i don't want to cry on
my own violin here but
you know
when tony died jillian and i had just
finished doing you know co-directing
co-producing the second parts unknown
that we made for him and
it was in florence it's a show that has
not aired it was never finished
we shot it a week before tony died
and we were sitting with tony on the
last day and he turned to jillian and uh
he you know he gave her his seal of
approval i said i i like this i like
working with you
we're gonna do this a lot more i just
signed another three years
and uh and like buckle up get ready
and that was the last interaction
the three of us had together and jill
and i went home that night we looked at
each other like we did it
you know we did it and we did this is
the dream we're on the we're on the
coolest [ __ ] show on tv
the best ride you can possibly go on if
you're
you know a sensualist who wants to see
the world this is it and it doesn't get
better than this
we're doing it together we're able to
bring our kids the next show that we
talked about potentially doing was in
kyoto it's like you know who doesn't
want to do that
we had the dream
and we had worked really hard to get
there and a week later that was gone
and that was a tough blow and so
we've
you know i don't know we've just focused
in on like okay cool how do we get back
there
and that's i mean man that's so
important to me yeah
she's also super super good at what she
does so it makes it easy
now she's outgrowing me though because
everyone wants her quality problems and
sounds like you have
sounds like you both have great
co-pilots for kids and daddy longlegs
and everything in between going pretty
well yeah man well moe let me do this
because i know um
you have uh you have a lot going on over
there and we've already been gone for
almost three hours that's so much fun
this is so great man it's so wonderful
to see you and i'm so happy to see you
doing so well with the family and
is there anything else you would like to
say
share any requests you'd like to make of
the audience any complaints about the
podcast you'd like to state publicly
anything at all that you'd like to add
before we wind to a close here oh man
there's so many things you know like go
through like when we were gonna do this
i was just going through all this these
incredible experiences in my mind it's
too much to get into one thing yeah but
i did want to talk about one day that i
felt like it was like you know really
the best day of my career and i feel
like really got to typify what the whole
experience was about and
then i don't know if this will make the
cut or anything anyone wants to hear my
anecdotes but you know we did this this
show in antarctica which was a huge show
for us and i think was really
showed it was a real expression of what
i was talking about like you can't buy
this ride you got to earn this with
something special like that show
we get invited to go down to antarctica
i mean you know now i uh you've been you
know you fly to christchurch
hapa c-130 to mcmurdo
and then from mcmurdo we we hopped
another c-130 to the south pole like we
had our own c-130 like how ridiculous is
that
like me and tony and the rest in the
crew it was actually the show was
directed by eric osterhoff so i got to
like give him mad props for getting us
down there and produced by josh farrell
who was like also just like a great
producer and
co-dp on that was fred minnow who's a
gifted
cinematographer
and we also had josh flanagan who is uh
one of our other
dps who's also just gifted on this show
so we have this incredible crew we had
our own freaking c130 flying around
and we did this thing where we went out
to a place called dry valleys which is
it's kind of like they get if you go to
antarctica you hang out at mcmurdo dry
valleys is interesting because they've
had no precipitation for like you know
10 000 years right so you're in
antarctica but
it looks like you're in the desert
people don't know this there's places in
aeronautical where there's no snow
where we were is kind of mixed you get
glaciers and you get like rock
right so we go
have this incredible meal this crew
that's there we're drinking whiskey out
of
ice that's
these little shot glasses they make out
of the ice there that's 50 000 years old
icing our drinks it's 50 000 years old
there's a beach there next to the so
we're so we're like sitting on the beach
tony's playing music as he always would
he would be like the dj we'd drink
shoot a little play frisbee shoot the
[ __ ] talk
just kind of soak it up it's like you
know bright sunlight 12 at night
he was playing specifically he was
playing gin and juice i remember that
and we're all just having a great time
we go to sleep
camp out next to the glacier there and
wake up the next morning and the next
morning we were just going to shoot
b-roll and we get picked up by a
helicopter right an a-star that's
piloted by a pilot who had been flying
apaches and cobras in afghanistan and
then like
got to go down and and be one of these
pilots on the ice but when you're a
pilot down there basically all you do is
you either pick up human waste and
shuttle it back to mcmurdo from these uh
substations or you're like you know
ferrying scientists and samples back and
forth like you don't really get to do a
lot of fun stuff but then we're like the
rock and roll crew that comes in
and we get this pilot who's just hot to
trot and like oh do you want to go see
some [ __ ] and we're like yeah we want to
go see some [ __ ] and just took us on a
tour of all the craziest [ __ ] that he
could get to within
fuel range of of that substation and
like
you know flying through these canyons
and no one's ever been in
you know fly you up to a cliff that's 2
000 feet high
the scale of antarctica cannot be
described you'd be like we'd be on this
cliff that's 2000 feet high looking down
into a valley where you could easily fit
manhattan
with room left that no one's ever
touched it's vast beyond belief standing
in a place where no human being's ever
been
pop back in the helicopter and then he'd
do some crazy drop off the cliff where
you're like weightless for a second go
fly around and going through canyons and
just everything you ever wanted to do if
you ever had a helicopter and an apache
pilot to yourself
and we're filming and filming filming
and eventually we need fuel
we stop at this refueling station
there's intermittent refueling stations
around and we're sitting there
surrounded by 55 gallon drums of jet
fuel and these three folks come out and
they are the people who work at the
refueling station and their job is to be
out there all season long right
refueling choppers
pretty lonely out there i bet
at that point you are living on hoth you
know
and
they come out with these pulled pork
sandwiches like they made pulled pork
sandwiches for us and we're so sitting
there drinking warm coffee
eating pulled pork sandwiches
over a 55-gallon drama of uh
jet fuel
the helicopter's still hot
and just had this moment of
this is this is it man this is the top
for this particular thing that i'm going
to do in my life this particular journey
nothing is going to get any
cooler than this
nothing is going to get any more
singular inaccessible or amazing to be
able to do those things and see those
places
and to hope to be able to capture enough
of that in an organic enough way
that it would translate some of what
that journey was to people at home who
will never be as lucky as i've been to
stumble into this thing and to be able
to hang out and hang on and
and get to that place
that was that was it man and like
i don't know it feels kind of selfish to
tell that story in a way
because
it's like oh look at you know look at
the awesome [ __ ] thing that i got to
do but i actually don't mean it that way
i actually mean like
i hope that what we did at the end of
the day
was was
be able to bring some of that back and
show people
what is out there
it is
vast and beautiful and extraordinary
and
so much bigger than our little daily you
know kind of day-to-day context and not
trying to belittle or trivialize that
but there's something very freeing about
the humility that comes with those
massive spaces and
being able to say like no one's ever
stood here this ice is 50 000 years old
or this is timeless this goes so much
deeper and beyond me i don't know i hope
that maybe everyone gets to to
experience
some degree of that at some point in
their life because
i i think it's really important
to be able to feel small
and ultimately that is what the show did
i guess for me and like the best way is
give me a perspective on what this world
really is
you know fyi we should [ __ ] take care
of it
you know yeah and don't be so goddamn
afraid of other people man at the end of
the day like could keep telling people
what i saw out there you know seven
continents 70 countries and a lot of
hairy moments a lot of beautiful moments
and a lot of whatever
99 of the people that we encountered
were just
beautiful awesome people that wanted to
take us into their homes and feed us
and and share their life with us and
tell us who they were
and that's the truth of what's out there
there's a lot of othering that goes on
in this world and like
they're not same concerns same people
all of them
same [ __ ] we're trying to do
same same
i don't know if that makes sense kind of
a rant that makes perfect sense and that
i could
i could not have scripted a better place
to end and i'm glad that there's no
scripting involved man it's uh
the perfect place to wrap up mo it's so
nice to see you again
yeah man it was great really really
great to see you
hopefully we can hang out in person at
some point here too oh i would love that
i would love that and people can find
you on twitter at diamondmo mo fallon if
let me let's try that yeah i figured
with an f of my name i can say that
correctly at diamond mo fallon and we
already got the mobart f-a-l-l-o-n
instagram
fallon.morgan
facebookmorgan.fallon.com
and
0.0 you can find all spelled out 0.0.com
thank you so much for making the time
yeah come be another one of my uh
disappointed and frustrated social media
followers
i don't do great on social media
oh that is the perfect way to get people
to look at your social brilliant
genius absolutely genius
and really appreciate you and what you
do in the world and the
ruggedness and rigor
that you bring to what is both
incredibly
artistic but and i saw this when we were
working together also very tender and
and human
it's a gift that you help bring to the
world so thank you for
for doing that
[ __ ] tim i mean it's it's an incredible
compliment coming from you and
everything that you do and
and bring and i think you bring that
same humanity to everything that you do
that's like a real marker of your
success so i i mean listen i'm humbled
man by the whole thing so thank you
thanks to you man and
we'll we'll get together have some
coffee maybe go mountain biking on
something that isn't like
in a 45 degree single single track yeah
and i'll let you get to the daddy long
legs and for everybody listening for
links to everything we discussed
everything we talked about and more
i will put that all in the show notes at
tim.blog podcast and until next time
be just a little bit kinder than you
think is necessary
and thanks for tuning in
you